as you were talking earlier i could
literally see a giant beat of cigarettes
i've got the [ __ ] sun staring at me
and we don't even [ __ ] have the ac on
the price that we you know maybe in
water spray let's go
hello and welcome to another episode of
trash taste i don't know what episode
number this is anymore because it's
probably going to be out of order anyway
i'm your host for today gant and joining
me once again are the boys you know who
they are what are you wearing guys
i just okay it's it's it's summer now
okay i need to bring the summer energy
okay i'm like channeling every
like dad doing a barbecue right now you
look like if trevor from gta 5 got a tan
[Laughter]
look at that with the one too many
camera lenses you know what i mean
you're like oh i don't know what he's
getting up to those lenses you know what
i mean
dad that goes bird watching
you really need a 500 millimeter lens
that's like this long like is there a
come on come on please gta vice city
once okay i've got to miami
but uh how are you guys in like
surviving japanese summer like how hot
is it today jesus it's like 35 i think
well yesterday was 35. yeah you know
what let me start off with something i
hate it when you can't complain about
the weather where you're from it's like
you know what i i said on twitter i was
like i can't i'm dying man it's 35
degrees and then someone replies like
it's like 42 here i'm like that is not
something to be proud of you live in a
[ __ ] like the actual sun
i [ __ ] hate that [ __ ] like no matter
how hot it is where you are and you
could be [ __ ] dying in the sahara
desert or something you get to you get
to like the nearest town you're like
[ __ ] man i just survived the sahara and
someone from texas or somewhere and be
like oh how hot was it how hot was it
you didn't measure it when you measure
it
where i am a little [ __ ] no because
what i've realized okay i've like living
in japan has made me change my opinion
because before
okay so before moving to japan or before
like moving on to totally unrelated
it's not totally unrelated because
before moving to japan or moving out of
england my favorite season was summer
okay yeah i was i was we've discussed
this in the podcast before and we were
like yeah
or maybe it was just off camera
i remember we were like talking about
because i think you and i both like the
winter like much much more winter's
worth season lots
off winter's worst season maybe this
should become a conversation that we
have every single year the summer turns
around and everyone's like you guys
spoke about this already i'm like it's
in my head shut up no because like i i
didn't realize that uh
it's like summer wind uh summers in
england are actually pretty good and
that's why summer was my favorite season
that doesn't get in england it's like 25
degrees celsius summer yeah that's the
thing right that's the thing no no it
gets hotter than that god that gets
harder one there's someone the summer
before we left right yeah but that one
week is pure hell because uk we don't
have air conditioning just doesn't exist
true in homes yeah the one time i went
to the uk it was during that week it's
horrible because you know at least in
japanese summer it's like oh [ __ ]
walking outside [ __ ] this is
it's it's way worse but you can just go
in any any building anywhere and you're
like oh cool
they've got the they've got yeah they've
got the ac running at full like full
blast like it's good but in the uk
you have no escape in the uk it's like
maybe the gym has ac the supermarket
probably has it but like that's it like
when you go home you're like
put on the tv
yeah cause like what do you do to cool
down in the uk have like nine fans on
you so so you do have bands yeah but
fans don't do [ __ ] yeah fans don't do
[ __ ] fans are like that's just
dissipating
placebos yeah of like you're like yeah
it's definitely doing something you're
like why am i still sweating so much
like
because all it is is just taking the
stagnant hot air and just moving it
around right yeah occasionally i just
like you go up to it you know i put my
shirt over the fan yeah i'm like this is
true cooling that's that's the best
feature
maybe it's a nostalgia thing for me
because growing up or like spending my
summers in thailand uh you know um in
thailand we tried to save costs as much
as possible you know so
like the ac is always like the last
resort that's like when we're literally
like dying of heat stroke yeah any other
time it's just like come on you can
survive with the fan so like i spent
most of my like time and experience
being cooled down by a fan and ac was
just like okay if we don't put the ac on
we're probably going to die here so it's
it's i think that's why it's like kind
of nostalgic for me like
i kind of like the fan like i kind of
like the female fan just just on me but
i admit like if you're not used to it
like i felt sorry when you visited
yanaki visited us in the uk because you
have to subscribe yes yes sleep in my
room and we that was like there was one
fan in there there was a single fan in
like my entire house like joey you can
have the fan and i was like i don't
think i actually did anything for you
i was butt [ __ ] naked in your bed i'm
like i'm still dying it sucks it it
doesn't help and it doesn't get cold
during the night the fan yeah i get like
the whole like fan being nostalgic
though because like i have that exact
same thing at my suffering is nostalgic
for me
at my grandma's old place in the middle
of nowhere in the mountains yeah we
didn't have ac
it was just because the house was too
big to have a single ac unit yeah like
also all the doors were always open so
it was always with a fan yeah but is it
it's nostalgic
is it good memories though no
i love just dying slowly
that was the time when i almost died of
heat in my grandma's house good times
you might be confusing nostalgic with
like ptsd
i like i like the feeling of like i
prefer the heat the feeling of summer
over winter like any day of the week i
don't know i'm just like i'm just
depressed in winter winter's just like
even even like dying in this heat i
still prefer
what i'm experiencing experiencing now
to winter what what happens to you in
the winter
yeah what happens which is just the
worst scene to [ __ ]
it is it's the worst season okay okay
okay yeah i think it's like
scientifically proven that
people are less people are more happy
with more sunlight right
i think it's literally more healthier
for you to get more sunlight because you
are literally happier see more there is
sunlight in the window there's like
barely any sunlight in the winter and
okay here's here's the thing that
depresses me the most okay especially if
you're working a nine-to-five job you
have to commute to work you wake up it's
you wake up maybe seven a.m or whatever
if if you have to commute long it's like
seven eight a.m you wake up it's dark
you go to the office at nine and it's
still just like the sun's just rising i
love you stay
you stay inside literally all day you're
just in the office with after artificial
light you go out it's 5 p.m and again
it's dark i like that i like the night
how could
like how can you look how could you not
want any sunshine in your life
you know most of the time i have my
curtains closed
too hot even
in my office now i have them closed all
the time and like the second thing
everything's dead in the winter there's
there's no color at all you look outside
everything's gray everything's drab how
can you be happy with like zero color i
don't know i i just think you're you're
a boring person
like like literally the only thing to
look forward to in winter is christmas
like i'm pretty sure they're interesting
about christmas i'm pretty sure they
invented christmas because if they
didn't have christmas like everyone
would just have nothing to look forward
to objection i'm from australia we
didn't have such thing okay
you know i don't know it's it's fun it's
cozy you know you get to it's yeah it's
cozy you get to also you get the most
drip in winter you know like i agree
okay that you get no drip in there
i wouldn't be wearing this i wouldn't i
wouldn't be wearing this drip in the
winter
you get the best drip and you get the
best sleep
yeah the sleep is clean yeah i don't
know the sleep the window open a little
bit sometimes it's kind of chilly
nice it's like you're kind of like it's
kind of like just it's not cold but it's
like a little bit like oh okay maybe i
could you know put something light on
but the moment you hop in that bed and
you put that blanket over you and you're
just wrapped in a warm cocoon there's
like i'm unstoppable this sleep is on my
side now and you just get the best
[ __ ] sleep yeah the mornings suck but
yeah the mornings dude for me all the
mornings suck i can't wake up in the
morning so it doesn't make a [ __ ]
difference to me
okay the only thing i could say i will
say is that i can wear turtlenecks in
the winter exactly
would they be steve jobs without weird
sucks because you your options are so
limited in the winter it's like
shorts but that's the last but that's
why i like british summers because what
i realized is that british summers is
just like a comfortable like it's it's a
comfortable temperature most of the time
pre-global warming yes
it was good because you know this didn't
used to happen and it was never like
this in the uk where it was that bad i
remember we always complain about
british summers to be like every like
every british person i've met is just
like oh you haven't experienced british
summer it's like really it's it's rain
sometimes it's cold sometimes and i'm
just like it's like it actually slaps
compared to other subjects i would
compare to other places yeah i would
have agreed with you until like two
years ago when for some reason two years
in a row which had horrible heat waves
that just ruined the summer for me
because it was always fun in the uk the
best part about it is i like it in
summer when the day is hot and the night
gets cool yeah but in japan it doesn't
get cool oh it does
no i think it does no compared to like
compared to now like because you know
it's like what [ __ ] 2 p.m right now
it is like the hardest time of the day
right now right yeah yeah but compared
to that euro yeah carry on
but compared to that when it's you know
the sun finally goes down like what like
8 00 p.m yeah maybe and like around like
nine or ten it's like it's pretty
comfortable that's that's the kind of
weather where i'm like okay i'm really
comfortable i can't concentrate with
that guy
we're gonna cut
max you're right what's wrong with you
all of a sudden i don't know guys i just
wanna least suddenly ride a mech and bat
a lot of people to prove that i'm the
best mecca pilot ever how can i satisfy
this sudden urge you guys
well i'm glad you've asked i've got just
the thing for you gone macarena it's the
new casual mobile game shooter on
android and ios hop in your mech play a
game or two cause some chaos and be out
in just a few minutes anyone can play
and you don't need to be a pro gamer to
have some fun i've actually tried it out
and i really like the guardian mech you
can shut down enemy abilities like
shields or stuns and it forces the enemy
to completely reload their weapons with
just a push of a button the enemy is
danzo that sounds ops it sure is gone my
favorite mech is the panther it has the
ability called the stasis barrier put
down an invincible wall that blocks
enemy bullets and slows anyone that
passes through it if you like to
maintain a distance and snipe down your
enemies this mac is for you that sounds
like a very cool mac and even better god
no no
no
what is that a box what are those
opening up joey
what are you waiting for all right first
of all we've got to scan this qr code
once you scan that in we have these
character cards
oh okay look at that oh i'm in like
the room
how did you get that it's actually kind
of cool so apparently there's a poster
in here that you can also scan oh
oh that looks cool that actually looks
cool well while you guys are doing that
let me uh check out some of the other
things inside this box oh my god this
thing's so heavy so i assume this is a
make arena coaster
man that's got that's got some weight to
it
it's like a birthday card but it's like
it's it's it's not only that it's like a
legit screen
oh my god it's like an actual tablet
inside
and it just stops when you close it let
me see that let me see let me see that
let me see that all right ready for it
that's actually so cool
we have also uh what looks like to be
the mech arena art book or a little uh
art pamphlet that shows all of the
concept art i guess you can just keep
the tablet because there's even a
charger inside of it yeah i think so
what i assume
i think we just literally just got a
free tablet oh and by the way that's not
the coolest thing that's in here because
there's also one more thing if i can
even get it out hell yes get it out we
got a little figure oh look at that oh
marina figure look at that now you can
finally get in the robot yeah oh yeah
and also we've got the macarena t-shirts
oh yes where's my t-shirt nice where are
you our t-shirts crew throws a t-shirt a
macarena t-shirt yes assert dominance on
the max with these mecharina t-shirts
too i'm in the mac arena make arenas
just launched globally they're running a
huge celebration event in-game right now
with loads of awesome events as well as
a great login reward program which you
definitely don't want to miss out it's
completely free to play right now and
you can use the link in the description
or scan the qr code here to get one
black carbon skin 300 a coins 50 000
credits to help kickstart your game and
if you're lucky you might even get to
team up with one of us and get to play a
game or two together i'm getting in the
robots right now
back to the episode well like i like
that i like having as much as i said as
much sunlight as possible and i just i
feel like the best
like my favorite time period of the
entire year is about like what's what's
the word like dusk summertime when like
the sun's setting it's about seven eight
pm and you're just watching the sunset
man you feel like a [ __ ] anime
character because it's just like it's
just you know it's it's it's that
[ __ ] scene where you're just like
where the [ __ ] dude in every opening
where like they're the protagonist is
watching the sunset and the wind's just
blowing how often you are you're
standing out how old are you
being like how the [ __ ] are you watching
it yeah how often are you watching this
shut the [ __ ] up no it's anime shut the
[ __ ] up
scene on tatooine right where he's like
watching the sun go down how often how
often are you watching the sunset
honestly that's why i love my balcony
that's why i have a hammock out there
because oh no you [ __ ] off you're not
watching the sunset every day i'm not
watching it i'm not watching it every
day but the hottest time of the day in
my opinion because you're getting that
like direct [ __ ] sunlight the whole
time of the day is [ __ ] now i can't
stand out there
it's hot until the sun goes down
like the moment the sun rises it's the
hottest time of the day
no
no i mean i don't know man i like going
outside and i don't want to have to
[ __ ] you know
shed away my life expectancy to just go
outside yeah i guess that's why for me
in japan i think my favorite season is
probably spring
for me it's the autumn autumn yeah like
around like october it's probably my
favorite time of the year just because
it's like again you have that
you know variance in drip right you can
wear a jacket if it gets a little bit
cold in the night but you can take it
off and you know rock a long sleeve
right but it's also not so cold that
it's excruciating but it's not too hot
either
you know
i feel like that's the same spring
though and i like the i like the whole
have we talked about hanami at all like
the cherry blossoms sir i mean like so i
i mean you've you know you you watch
anime right you know what cherry cherry
is awesome you know what [ __ ] cherry
blossoms i will lie i was slightly
disappointed to find out that cherry
blossoms are only around for like one
week and they [ __ ] off because i'm like
hold out there and
all the anime all the time what's going
on with that yeah they film all the
anime in the same week
i realized it's like a cult in japan
like they they're obsessed with this
they had on me like everything revolves
when hanumi's coming up everything is
hanami yeah like well yeah everything
has to become cherry blossom it's like
everything everyone just joins like a
caller because there's a really like
extensive history right right but it's
like it's nuts like it's i understand
why it's an anime so much now but when i
got here i'm like wow literally
everything is decorated like like it's a
call of duty gun skin it's like
everything's there every it doesn't
matter what it is it gets a cherry
blossom skin i mean not gonna lie man
like a good honey is [ __ ] dark yeah
yeah but it's good it is disappointing
it's really weird yeah
this week yeah this year this year i'm
sorry
i didn't do anything this year because i
i i totally forgot i didn't know when it
was coming i i had one of the best
harmonies this year i'd rather enjoy me
river it's just like rows and rows of
sakura trees do you want to explain what
hanami is to the viewers
literally means flower watching yeah in
japanese so it's it's basically this
kind of i wouldn't even say it's like a
festival it's more like an event that
happens isn't it even a public holiday
no i feel like it's a mutual agreement
amongst everyone to get drunk in the
park yeah that's kind of what it is
pretty much pretty much but it's yes
it's like because the sucker are only
around for about a week and some maybe
sometimes not even a week later a couple
of days yeah uh people go out and like
celebrate by just sitting under a tree
having a picnic under the sucker tree do
you think it's [ __ ] great do you
think it's worth because i know a lot of
people who are like i want to come to
japan during that time do you think it's
worth coming japan just for it i think
because i think if it's the first time
you come into japan i think it's worth
yeah i think now because we've lived in
japan for two years we're kind of like
we're kind of like used to it but i feel
like seeing hanami for the first time
and seeing like all like the cherry
blossoms just like falling off the trees
and you have like the ground is
literally covered in cherry blossoms
yeah like everywhere i think that's a
pretty cool like a couple of years
definitely just nodded to you saying
that right now it's like oh it's like in
the end like you literally walk through
a park and it's lit it is literally like
every [ __ ] anime scene where like the
[ __ ] cherry blossoms yeah the cherry
everywhere watering down
still looks dark it looks dope as [ __ ] i
like
i don't know what it is japan that just
it's like so aesthetic but it's just
it's just the perfect aesthetic i mean
japan is like kind of aesthetic all year
round but i'd say like the most
aesthetic is probably during the suckers
i'd say if you are gonna do it
definitely get out of tokyo because like
every single hanami place in tokyo like
every single park that has the cherry
blossom trees is this packed
yeah yeah you you will be
like because we met two years ago we did
like a small one yeah and we had to get
like a corner of dirt
in the park right next to the road like
it was the only literally the only spot
left in this massive where did you guys
go like shinjuku no we we're in uh
saitama yeah
yeah yeah right and it was like
it was rammed as well it was so full
because what what people normally do
here in japan is during the cherry
blossom week or season or when they're
blooming uh people go to the park they
get like a kind of like a picnic area um
and then they just get [ __ ] pissed in
public right right it's great i'd say go
like when you come to japan definitely
do like a week in tokyo and then if you
if you're you know if it aligns with the
hanami do a week somewhere else where
you can then go and celebrate the hanoi
yeah i feel like doing because you can't
really explore japan in one week i don't
think no you can't you kind of explore
tokyo in one week yeah feel i've been
here for like two years now and i've
barely explored japan
how is hanami in like hakuna you said oh
i mean it's great because it's like i
mean hakuna is still you know very much
a tourist destination but i mean
compared to like shinjuku going or like
yogi park it's like yeah you don't get
any space at all no absolutely no space
at all and i mean like i i guess as well
like in hakuna and a lot of places in
hakone they've definitely like
positioned a lot of like uh onsens and
like yokans and stuff like that yeah
around the sakura and like around all
the aesthetic parts of hakone so
yeah it was great i mean like we we
stayed in like an airbnb that was
overlooking uh like a bunch of like
sakura trees on the lake and yeah in the
distance you could see mount fuji and it
was like the most like aesthetic [ __ ]
harmony that i ever had and i was like
you know what it's it's kind of worth to
go all the way out there sometimes to
just like get a little bit of peace of
mind right because otherwise it's just
be like you'd be rubbing shoulders with
the person next to you being like look
at the pedal over there oh my god
it wasn't the people it was like the
[ __ ] kids running around i mean like
getting pissed is great getting pissed
with like a bunch of like five
six-year-olds running around you like
playing football or whatever
it's not exactly like the best kind of
vibe to get pissed drunk if you're
sitting like where i am now you are
probably like this close to someone as
well yeah someone else is like
matt and picnic set well you see you
stayed in airbnb have you stayed in many
airbnbs in japan um
not really yeah i mean because like 90
of them got [ __ ] axe yeah so for the
olympics uh
the japanese government changed the the
rules around airbnbs basically just
gutting them and making it so that you
had to make it you did follow a lot of
but they basically made it so you had to
follow hotel rules like you had to have
like the fire escape and like the floor
lit up to the yeah it's they made it
they basically made the rules impossible
on purpose where you couldn't turn a
profit like reasonably basically because
i have stayed in an airbnb yeah i stayed
in one as well the first time i visited
it was super cheap you get like what do
we get me and alan got the airbnb for
what like
it was really cheap like 150 bucks yeah
but it was like a really really small
room i remember but it was right in
chennai
oh remember was that the one yeah that
was the one i got really sick in
whatever you threw up in
what i want to know okay so this was
like i think the first time you'd been
to japan it was my very first time very
first time
i was so confused i just turned up in
this
yeah i heard the instructions for this
airbnb that i didn't understand i had my
luggage and i was like what the [ __ ] is
going on yeah i was so confused like
yeah the side of the world and of course
connor flies over and the very first
thing we do uh once conor and alan come
over is that we go to karaoke and we
stay all night well we weren't going to
right so what happened was that i took
you guys to an izakaya oh yeah i was
only going to meet because you guys were
like oh we're too sleepy you're probably
just going to go to bed and then i think
you me and joey were like well sit well
i think this is my first time going to
japan i was like
finally i can show this i was like no
[ __ ] there's someone wrestling let's go
and get drinks yeah cause i was like jet
lagged and so was conor i think i mean i
mean you were jet lagged
you were running off you were running on
the excitement of yeah of course being
in japan for the first time show me
around let's go let's go drink so jen
jerry julia like a very uh like i told
you
during the weekday where they have 100
yen beers yeah yeah yeah and connor was
mine was just [ __ ] i was like a
dollar
i was like this is insane this is like
60p this is like beauty prices not even
the union prices don't even get this low
this is this was insane yeah
this is a beer right like legit like a
legit beer yeah
yeah we were drinking and then mommy and
jerry were getting drunk yeah i think
they were gone and uh we had just landed
and we were like they were like you know
what no we don't want to miss out so
then they came and started drinking and
then we went out of karaoke yeah and
then we were staying tonight and i got
very sick
but i want to know because i know joey
joey got a very sick if you know what i
mean i had to stay around your place um
who slept on the floor
dance editor and so this was
november yeah no yeah november yeah no
january
it was like basically it was [ __ ]
freezing yeah it was really cool we had
to have the ac running in the room
problem was is that there was a door
there was literally no room for anyone
else to sleep in this room to have two
people yeah because i remember going to
your place i'm just like how the [ __ ]
did you fit three people in here it's
literally a shoe box yeah and yeah so
basically allen had to sacrifice his bid
for me and he slept in the hallway
alan the tallest [ __ ] yeah and
by by hallway it was literally like just
a single like very
like it was slipped on the floor it was
like a human-sized corridor you could
not like fit anything more than just
like a [ __ ] it was like it was like
minus five it was a really cold yeah he
was just like like i because i wasn't
aware that allen had you know given up
the bed and slept yeah
and it wasn't until i woke up that
morning and i kind of came to and i was
like where the [ __ ] am i
and then i saw connor in his bed on the
other side and i was like oh okay i'm in
there
airbnb and i was like where's alan and
then i just saw this like lump
in the hallway yeah yeah like i just
like just there's a lump of like
blankets
yeah and i was like is that how is he
dead
he literally slept in like the [ __ ]
shivering hallway for me he's that one
friend who's like the nicest guy when
you're like sick or like when you drank
too much he's always got your back yeah
i threw up one time and he and even
though he was drunk he cleaned it all up
and i just went back to bed
that was the very first time i hang out
with you the first time i met him as
well yeah first first first time you
guys met right yeah and he cleaned up my
me throwing up absolute chat
that's how i know like from that point
onwards i was like amazing friends with
him because i was like this guy's got my
best yeah no one else will do nothing i
would never do that for someone i'm like
i'm i'm going back to bed yeah yeah yeah
you can do all this time because i
remember i remember it was like kind of
like a house party we had in england
where we kind of like rented out an
airbnb um and just like caught up
and you were like the new guy yeah i was
like 20 as well so i was still like yeah
let's drink way too much yeah i remember
alan telling the story of like i think
everyone was passed out and it was just
you and alan awake and your guys was
like sleeping on the sofa or something
and then like i think he made eye
contact with you have you made eye
contact with him and he just started
laughing and then he just watched you
and how you just like looked at him
laughed and just chunded everywhere
that sounds good
i remember
what was it you made some drink with
like really budget energy drink
all right from that day
yeah i swore never to drink budget
energy drink even even energy drink is
bad enough but the budget one where it's
like 50 cents for two liters is like
it's like brake fluid like no one like
of course you're gonna throw up drinking
that stuff i'm glad i did because i
didn't have to digest yeah exactly but
jesus
yeah we
have a mate from home uh who's now
like discovered a new cocktail is what
he calls it it's not a cocktail it's
literally like okay tell me how
disgusting this sounds it's boost so a
boost so
budget red ball yeah uh boost and red
wine
oh my god
that's oh
jesus does he have like a functioning
like taste buds and i'm just like
i thought we grew out this in university
man that can't be not even uni students
stoop that loaded like i think if you
did that in france you'd be deported yes
rick i'm calling you out right now it's
disgusting stop trying to get me to
drink it that's so vile
yeah
what would i even take like could you
even taste the energy drink at that
point because red the the flavor of red
wine is so overpowering
i feel there's some things where even if
even if that tasted amazing i'm like no
this is
morally wrong this is too broke for me
like this is so broke
and there's nothing wrong with that i
just don't want to partake in it
you can be broke nice
no no it's fine it's fine it's not poor
it's broke it's different broke is a
mindset
poverty and being poor is you you are
just your finances don't be poor just
being broke is the mindset of like i'm
gonna live like an animal and i you know
i don't i don't partake in that you know
you can be rich but be broke at the same
time
listen the reason why if you're homeless
just no no that's poverty god that's
different there's a difference to
poverty it broke
big difference guy come on
like there's a difference he's trying to
get me in a corner here saying being
poor is bad yes it is gone you want me
to say
i mean you're not doing a very good job
of fighting like pushing your arms
you can clearly afford red wine and you
can clearly afford energy drink why
would you mix them that is like that is
you're making yourself broken for no
reason you know is that broke that's
broke that's broke i don't drink energy
drink period anymore i don't know at
what age it was where i was just like
man red bull kind of sucks doesn't do
anything for me anymore actually no i
drink those i don't know if it counts is
it andrew drink the uh or i'm on c
oh yeah that's kind of weird i don't
know if i count that as an issue i love
those things yeah it's like a vitamin
drink it's a vitamin drink that's
definitely not healthy but it's in the
same like section as like oh you mean
you mean the japanese ones yeah it's
like a glass it's like a glass thing
it's got a really satisfying pop yeah
like you pull this metal tab in it
really a really nice pocket
i think yeah um it's this on screen i
don't know what definitely if you if you
kind of like sweet drink i don't know
who because i don't really drink genji
drinks but i love this thing yeah it's
so tasty i feel that works better than
any drink yeah i don't know if it's
placebo but yeah i mean it definitely
tastes a lot better for my body than a
red bull i think i don't feel awful
after drinking that yeah i think it's
because now it's gone to the point where
if i have an energy drink it's literally
going to make me unable to sleep for
that night and it never used to be that
way normally i could like down
five energy drinks or whatever and like
be fine the night so you have the
opposite problem i don't i don't get
anything from them anymore all right
that's cause you're doing like [ __ ]
five cups of coffee a day i'm not
[ __ ] surprised maybe
i can quit any time
just replace coffee with energy drinks
all right yeah exactly yeah i quit
coffee i only just drink a lot of tea
when i stopped drinking them yeah but
tea also has caffeine yeah much though
doesn't he have more caffeine
without like the tea it like itself if
you just eat tea yeah but i like the tea
leaves yeah yeah
tea if you would just eat the tea leaves
oh okay like if you would just eat it
yeah you'd be taking more caffeine but
no one does that sorry
you said that
eat tea you know what i mean british
people be like
[Laughter]
i don't drink it
sure if you just like [ __ ] just like
you know powder the coffee on your food
or whatever get caffeinated
why did you start caring about what you
were putting in your body
i mean i still don't care
what
what
trying to stop thinking about that [ __ ]
off okay i i care when i can feel the
effects does that does that make sense
does that make sense no
i guess
you mean like the immediate effects yeah
like if like oh i have a tummy ache
immediately afterwards but i probably
shouldn't put it in my body yeah so like
i can just tell we're about to get on an
american topic this is gonna you know
what i mean like i feel like america's
gonna die
okay no like there was a point i i feel
like where you could just put any [ __ ]
in your body and you could just not feel
any like after effects at all it would
just like go away after a while but now
like i have gotten to a point where for
example i try to keep a healthy sleep
schedule because if i don't get a
healthy sleep schedule i just feel like
[ __ ] and i don't know i don't
i just feel like there was a point when
i didn't care about a sleep schedule and
it didn't matter so you like discover
sleep for the first time
i think your sleep schedule you know
when you've got [ __ ] to do that's right
that's it right that's it when you've
got [ __ ] to do and you want to be
productive like not like waking up late
actually affects that and i'm just like
yo um i never thought about this when i
was a uni student because i did
everything at 4am in the morning and i
still got a passing grade yeah right
so i'm jealous of youtubers who get
cancelled you know they just get like
they just gotta take a break they just
get to like [ __ ] off for four months you
know what i mean like this is just
getting canceled you get a sleep sketch
i'm like [ __ ] off man you cancelled him
he gets to take a four month like paid
vacation his videos are still getting
views what are you on about like
this man this is gonna come back and
come back in five months david david
dobrik got two month vacation that's all
he got
this is [ __ ]
so what's it what is the right amount of
time for like a youtuber council break i
don't know mate but the more the more
the more when i saw david dobrik and he
came back zero repercussions his views
came as his video that he came back with
got the same amount of views dislikes
likes are amazing you've got amazing
likes yeah you know i'm like this man
got a [ __ ] month vacation this is
[ __ ] and he got he got free articles
about him he can get verified now on
twitter
he wasn't already but i was like what
the [ __ ]
there was like no no there was like no
repercussions and i'm like wow what what
what point is it like damn
cancer doesn't look too too bad right
now i mean
if if logan paul can literally come back
from showing a dead body i feel like
anyone can come back you know it's
joey said a joke is a joke please don't
cancel jerry
but i was just thinking about it because
you saying that like oh um my mom made
many jumps and logic there um
because you were saying oh yeah well
you've got [ __ ] to do but when you you
know when you where you as youtubers you
always have [ __ ] to do because there's
no vacations you can't just take a month
off
people take a month off for a mental
health break which is like i say with
inverted commerce because it's kind of
become a cliche now even though it's
very important and beautiful they just
[ __ ] need it but you know it's sad
because if you get cancelled you almost
get a better vacation because
there's people still talking about you
while you're gone and people like
searching about you and making videos
about you like i know that sounds awful
and you know it's not great but like you
are still getting way more traffic yeah
than he would be just taking a break
right so if you do something kind of
semi semi bad you know just something
that's like
do something light you know just just do
something like oh just i don't know just
fart on a dog or something i don't know
just something that's like not too bad
what's something that you can you'll get
backlash for but isn't really that bad
that you can just come back from in a
month you know what i mean and then
you'll get your cat vodka
yeah perfectly fine you know yeah
starting to think i should get a pet
okay that's a joke
that's a joke that's a joke this is a
trash taste getting cancelled speed run
yeah
i just thought about it and i was like
hold on a second all these people just
get like
basically paid vacation this is [ __ ]
i mean i think it's like different
severity yeah the people get like quite
severe yeah it's quite bad but i've
noticing more and more a lot of them
just
if they haven't really done anything
criminal
they just kind of like bounce back super
easily i mean there are some people who
did cheat about that david was kind of
criminal to be fair let's be honest yeah
it was it was kind of criminal i mean
it's
endangered someone's life
came back all right like it just amazes
me it's like it's like jesus christ like
a cult yeah but then there's like
examples like edp four five five yeah
he's he's definitely not coming back
i mean he's trying to realize he's come
back edp was a youtuber who uh got
caught trying to meet up with 14 year
olds yeah and uh didn't he like try to
start his own website or something yeah
he did
did he actually yeah he did because he
he got his youtube band and then he was
like finna go to facebook you know it's
better than his facebook golfband yeah
facebook banned so he's like
finna start my own website
he's trying really hard man but yeah the
the main point of this whole me going on
this tangent was that uh yeah i feel
like yeah as youtubers you don't really
get a break i know we're complaining oh
boohoo
uh who cares i mean we have easy jobs so
whatever but i mean it's you know we
don't really get like set vacations
which sucks um and i kind of miss you
know one thing i really do miss doing is
just being able to two weeks off just
play video games
just catch up with [ __ ] like i don't
even want to go places anymore like
because i travel anyway on like weekends
or whatever i find three days here and
there that's fun but it feels like
you're still doing something but i just
want that that i miss that feeling of
like i'm gonna take two weeks off catch
up to all the movies catch up to all the
manga just can't play all video games
you know maybe might start persona
probably won't just buy it just look at
it
so many games so many games in my
backlog that i just want to play like
the new mass effect remaster got
released and i'm just like i want to
play that but i'm going to i haven't
even played persona 5 royal yet and [ __ ]
it [ __ ] knows where i'm going to get the
time to do that
yeah i now have two wish lists i have
the wish list where i will actually use
the thing and the wish list where this
is just a wish list where it would be
nice but i won't use it yeah yeah
it's the cancelled wishes yeah because
like you said you had a day the other
day where you just woke up and you did
nothing and it was i mean yeah i kind of
just woke up one day and i was like well
i don't really have any like videos to
work on i don't really have any like
other side projects to work on so i'm
just like you know what i'm i'm gonna do
a power move yeah not do anything like
not do anything without i didn't even
check my phone that day i was like no
phone turning off i'm just gonna do [ __ ]
around the house and just hang out and i
was like yeah damn is this what like a
weekend feels for every other i'm
literally experiencing a weekend for the
first time in my life i was like oh my
god this is f i should do this more
often yeah [ __ ] like i think for us
especially the last few months have just
been super [ __ ] busy with us building
this set and having to like film a bunch
of episodes to get ahead i remember we
had like what like this two-week period
where it was like we finished building
the set then we filmed a trash taste
episode every day for like yeah it was
like we had a recording session with
either trash taste or like a netflix
shoot or some kind of some kind of other
live stream every day for like two weeks
without any breaks on weekends or
anything that was brutal that was like i
was i was like close to burn out there
yeah i do film my schedule lap on planet
yeah
like i'm i'm jealous of you right i'm
jealous of you the most because you you
view streaming as a down time i'm just
like i
wish [ __ ] i wish my down time could be
work
i wish i could get paid i wish i could
be paid for my downtime i'll just enjoy
it and that's like people always
complain at me like oh make a stream
schedule i'm like nah bro because i just
i just do whatever i want but i just i
stream often like yeah around the same
times but people are like yeah why do
you need a stream schedule you literally
stream like three or four times a week
yeah because i i think to myself i most
of the time whether i decide to stream
is normally on the day that's normally
like if i've worked too much or maybe i
want to just chill out you know maybe
i've got too much work to do so i don't
want to do it because the moment i
commit to a schedule is when it's
working yeah yeah exactly if i say i
have to stream at this day it's work
yeah and then that's why i won't stop
having fun so well i mean like i guess
for you it's like good because you have
that one game that you can stream which
you also just play casually yeah i think
i think when you cause that's
right but it's it's right now but like
i'm you know i'm like so i mean i guess
totally my strengths
by the time this is out you would have
found out the winner of the tournament
arc 2 which we are currently being part
of yeah well we are because we were
recording these advanced because uh me
and gonna plan to get to the uk as we've
mentioned so uh yeah we're quite far
ahead right now but yeah we're in the
middle of the chess tournament so we're
playing a lot of chess recently yeah i'm
really enjoying um but yeah no i mean it
is i think when you are streaming it is
very helpful to have at least one game
that you can come back to when you're
like running out of ideas i think i
think that's what i'm currently trying
to find right now is that one game where
i'm just like the problem the problem is
my one game that i've just played a lot
it's just like not very popular yeah
and whenever i play it everywhere yeah
and whenever i play everyone's just like
oh he's obviously doing this because
it's a sponsored stream and i'm just
like no i just just enjoy the game no
one [ __ ] plays this game but i'll
play it i did notice that when i started
playing apex uh
because i
apex is probably the game i stream i've
streamed most um
that my viewership was quite much
considerably lower than normal but i was
like well no [ __ ] it i like this game
i'm going to keep playing it and then
after time it actually like went up to
the point where if i stream new games
now it's normally lower than apex yeah
this is a built up like the follow-up
but i feel like you have to you just
stick through
i feel like you also got very lucky as
well because the apex did just have a
massive boom in general yeah yeah
because of like every v tuber under the
sun
shadows yeah yeah apex raid of shadows
yeah yeah
yeah i don't know why that was not even
intentional i was just playing it and
then i started seeing every youtuber's
playing i'm like whoa what the [ __ ]
see like that's not going to happen with
my comfort game because my comfort game
is about 30 years old what's your
comfort game like any final fantasy game
oh yeah i'm just like like i can't i
can't like [ __ ] stream final fantasy
6 even though it's one of my favorite
games of all time because no one's going
to [ __ ] watch it and it sucks you
know well would you even want to stream
your comfort games
yeah i mean yeah because i think like
again it's like apex with conor where
it's like it's just a comfort game right
like you don't necessarily have to
see it as work or like you don't have to
necessarily be like entertaining and
wacky and goofy and you know yeah try
and hold an audience right like you can
just play a game casually yeah as you
would normally do and people would just
be there to watch you play it right yeah
it's different it's it's very different
to my normal streams as well i'd say
depends on what i'm doing like you're a
lot more quiet during your apex stream
yeah definitely yeah because i'm i'm
focusing on the game so it's like i talk
in between stuff happening yeah um so it
depends what's going on
but that's why i like i like talking to
japanese people on there it's fun yeah
like i'm trying to find more things that
i want to watch um that's that's like
that's i feel like i'm i'm more of like
i like doing passive things rather than
active things a lot of times in my
downtime like the other day uh like a
few days ago i ended up watching all of
loki for like the new marvel series it's
actually really [ __ ] good and like i
don't i'm not that invested in the
marvel franchise so i was like i'll just
put on one episode just see what it's
about and i just ended up binging the
entire thing and i was just like this is
[ __ ] amazing because it was only six
episodes but every episode is 40 minutes
long so i basically just binged an
entire season of anime just that's
that's how i think of things but it
wasn't anime but it was an anime and i'm
just like damn how why can't i do this
with anime anymore [ __ ] man i miss that
so much i'm so busy now where i like
dread good stuff coming out because i'm
like [ __ ] yeah i gotta find tana watch
this now see if only you could like
watch loki on twitch right just use that
as your down time just have people watch
just have watch parties yeah honestly i
would love to have watch parties with
like different things i'm watching yeah
but obviously dmca
obvious reasons can't do that yeah um
but like
because like i know sydney her her
downtime thing is that she watches
horror movies and
i don't know
how she finds so many [ __ ] horror
movies to watch i didn't know this many
horror movies existed she watches at
least three new horror movies every week
dude at least but the the successful of
horror movies is like never ending it's
actually insane because i was never i
i'm like i was never big into horror
movies i don't really like horror movies
um
and i assume you guys aren't big fans
either because none of it showed up on
our three by threes no i don't like not
a single one there's some good ones but
it's it's like it's not my favorite
genre yeah yeah yeah um but she somehow
finds so many shots huh shining is
really good shining's good i i like the
shine like there's only a few horror
movies that i really like shiny's one of
them i've really because like my my
taste in horror movies is really niche i
think because i like kind of loved
craftian horrors because i don't like
the usual like you know jump scares
ghost paranormal stuff what's the
problem is that so much horrors jump
scares now yeah it is it is cheap and
easy to relax yeah that's i think that's
why i'm such a big fan of like jinji ito
and stuff like that because it's really
like the horror that i like is really
just the ones that really unsettle me
like the macabre horror yeah yeah yeah
yeah no i i'm exactly like that like the
kind of like asian horror is like
definitely
more my taste in horror because yeah
again it's like you see like you know
you watch one paranormal activity you've
basically seen them all how the [ __ ] did
paranormal activity get so big it's
because steven spielberg greenlitted he
literally is that true yeah so i
actually read up on it because i had the
exact same thought i was like i saw
[ __ ] the trail of a paranormal
activity 73 and i was like yeah why are
there so many but i remember when it
when it came out i was in school and
ever everyone was like this is the
scariest movie ever yeah it's so scary
yeah i know right and i was just
everyone was like [ __ ] their pants
over it i remember because i was in
university at the time and so i was like
all right i'll see what the hype's about
because uh back then my roommates had a
watch party and then we watched uh
paranormal activity the first one and i
everything everyone was like jumping at
just like the [ __ ] closet opening and
i'm just like i can literally see the
[ __ ] string being used to open this
[ __ ] door how is this scary what is
going on
one remote press
one that i thought wasn't bad was it the
invisible men it wasn't that bad
actually is that what it's called oh the
invisible man yeah the one about the
invisible man
sydney showed me that one i like that
one it was all right yeah i quite like
that one yeah the cinema is pretty good
i enjoyed that one i like um i watched
the other day i finally watched um what
is it hereditary oh
oh how was that one because because i
missed out on it when it first came out
so i i kind of missed the initial hype
yeah because i was like western hearts
whatever for me yeah but then i think
felix showed me midsummer which is done
by the same guy arias yeah yeah and i
was like okay this is very creepy but
also kind of cool and experimental so i
was like all right well i heard
hereditary was pretty good i watched it
it's uh
it's weird i don't i wouldn't i almost
wouldn't even call it a horror film it's
like
i don't know it's you know what it feels
like it feels like if david lynch made a
horror film yeah you know okay where
it's like it's it's scary but it's also
as as we established in the previous
three by three joey the big arts knob
yeah david lynch
i feel like you just to make a good
horror movie you have to be [ __ ] up
yeah well
you'll just be completely [ __ ] up to
make any horror content i feel you need
to be [ __ ] up maybe in some aspects
actually uh me and sydney watched uh we
we had uh we had a night the other day
that we just kind of like binged part of
like the final destination series
and
the reason for that was because i kind
of i kind of remembered my very first as
a teenager i love those films yeah yeah
i remember the very first time i watched
final destination and was it was
actually in school right right um so i
think i was like i think it was like
middle school at the time so i was like
i think around 12 13 years old and i
don't know if the same thing for
australia but you know like at the end
of term in school right it's kind of
like a free frog and the teachers it's
kind of like that period where it's like
the last two classes of the year or
something teachers just let you let you
do whatever the [ __ ] you want right yeah
was that true in australia yeah i
definitely it depends on the school but
yeah yeah i think most schools it was
kind of just like
i'm going on break in [ __ ] three days
yeah whatever yeah so it was just like
it's just like in the school thousand
you just had a week period where you
just basically basically go to class and
every teacher would put on a different
film or just like roll in the team yeah
just roll just roll on the tv and
everyone will watch a different film and
like [ __ ] ninety percent of the time
it was shrek it was fun okay yeah okay
it was just awesome
yeah we watch shrek
good to know that that was just a
nationwide it's that time of year okay
end of year all right i guess it's shrek
again
and i remember this one class um one of
one of my classmates brought in a dvd
yeah right because
we were just
because the teacher would ask what does
everyone want to watch and so this guy
samuel
he he brings out the dvd and he brings
out final destination and he was like
this is this is a film i think the
entire class would want to watch and
everyone's like yeah sure anything
i think we were like 12 at the time
i had not heard a final destination at
the time but we're like yeah sure like
because like you know anything to get us
away from shrek or whatever
or whatever whatever the usual films
we're watching right so he was like miss
this i i think that the classroom would
watch would want to watch this and
nobody kind of like opposed it so and
the teacher had never heard of the film
before
okay so she was like dangerous so she
was like this boy just had this dvd on
him i i think he knew what he was doing
right yeah and so um so the film starts
off in final destination and characters
are always like it's it's i don't know
what the rating was like back then
but characters were
already swearing but
i think in pg films in like the uk even
if you have like one or two swear words
it can still be skewered towards like
the lower ratings if it's just like one
or two swelling i think so yeah yeah um
so like characters so i remember the
opening scene where they like get on the
plane and people start arguing whatever
um it's it's kind of sus because you can
hear people obviously swearing
and the teacher's just like uh samuel is
this
is is this suitable for this adrian is
like yeah miss don't worry it's just the
opening scene don't worry miss like just
don't worry about it and she's like okay
okay and so i remember the opening scene
is where like i i think it's it's where
the plane crashes that's the first final
destination i remember
so
so a bunch of 12 girls just watching
uh watching this plane take off and then
obviously um the plane starts to crash
uh the the wing snaps and everyone's
[ __ ] screaming it's terrifying right
in the scene and then you see like blood
splatter and then you see someone
getting burned alive
and
immediate
immediately like the [ __ ] the teacher
gets up aggressively like aggressively
gets off to the tv doesn't even doesn't
even switch it up unplugs the tv and
goes
samuel
get outside now
that was my very first experience at
final destination absolutely chad samuel
he was like he probably walked out i was
like worth it
i remember one of them put like uh it
was an art class i remember this and
like the teacher was not tech savvy at
all right and uh he put meat spin on all
the pcs
and then took just unplugged all the
mouse and keyboards and he the teacher's
having a mental breakdown didn't
understand why he couldn't just like he
was like [ __ ] hammering the keyboard
yeah like why was it turning off and
then i started hitting the monitor then
trying to turn the monitor off i don't
even think he knew how to turn it off
and then he didn't know how to turn it
off he didn't even think of unplugging
it or anything so this was still playing
the whole time and then goes and gets
another teacher to come around it's like
why don't you turn it off he's like oh i
didn't know how he pressed the button to
turn it off classic mead spin he's like
meat spin and there's like these poor
girls as well i've never seen this don't
look it up if you don't know what that
is because obviously we're all like 12s
that's if you're a guy and you're a
[ __ ] idiot yeah i mean it was
i mean it was like meat spin lemon party
i didn't know what goatee was that was
obviously like a few years past
that you came in the office like well
like a month ago i was like i just found
out what goats
or something right and we were like oh
how did you find that out right how did
you find out how did you find out about
goatsee in 2021 you you guys were the
ones who told me about it really yeah it
was it was like literally a recording a
trash taste and you were just telling
uh why was i talking about goats wait
this is in an episode oh this wasn't an
episode it was like before we started
you didn't know what it was no i didn't
i was like how did you have wait you
know what meat spit was you know what
goats i had to explain to god what goats
he was please don't look it up
some men spreading his butt cheese
it's 20 21 okay you don't need to know
what meat spin is or don't see these are
all just like people doing horrible
things yeah like people stuff yeah
pretty sure you can find way worse stuff
in the internet now anyway so yeah of
course you do yeah but that back back
when we were growing up this was just
like the [ __ ] you'd like show your mates
like [ __ ] hey there's this really
cool thing if you google meat spin oh
two girls one cup
is still scarring to this day yeah i
remember watching that yeah going back
to horror movies like i would like to
find
a horror movie i really liked has anyone
seen annihilation the one with natalie
portman
that sounds so familiar
uh there was a plot breakdown so the
plot breakdown is that
um there's an alien artifact or some
artifact from space that crash lands
um somewhere somewhere in the world
obviously and it creates this kind of
force field barrier right
and uh you can easily enter the barrier
but you can't get any like electrical
signals or any like communications
uh this features natalie portman and
hawkeye
not
no you're thinking of uh a rival that
was the one which i really like arrival
i hope that was good that was good
that's not a horror movie though oh i
thought it was okay yeah i mean it's
just a sci-fi oh okay yeah i just i just
wanted more sci-fi stuff which which i
think is why i was really going to loki
and so
and so
um
they can't get any
sorry they can't get any signals in
there so they don't know what's going on
in there and every team that they've
sent in there just never finds their way
out so they really they literally don't
know what's going on in there and this
force field is slowly slowly expanding
so eventually it will cover the whole
earth so they need to kind of stop it
right they need to kind of figure it out
and so
they send this team of scientists to go
investigate what's inside there and i
kind of won't spoil it from there
because a lot of sounds good a lot of
weird things happen and it's not like
it's not so what i liked about it is
it's it was just like really it's really
terrifying but not because of any jump
scares just some of the ideas within
this you know with some of the ideas of
what happens to the people within this
circle are just like really unsettling
and really terrifying it is very much
like a kind of like jinjito ideas where
it's just really weird kind of ideas
that you don't you kind of have to have
like i don't know what kind of mind you
need to come up with these things
uh but it's that i i would like more
horror like that and i don't know where
to start with recommendations which is
why if anyone if anyone knows any then
i'm all open what was that film with the
woman nicholas cage
and there's like numbers and there's a
kid who like has the knowing
that
i don't know how i remember that's the
one have you seen that movie yeah i've
seen that movie what is it
i can't remember but i remember being
really [ __ ] stupid
look at nicholas cage like he like stops
like a plane crashing or something no i
i think because i watched this as a kid
i remember he i i think it's like
something to be a series are we just
like trying to poorly recollect movies
like like what's this movie i want that
like this thing okay okay i'm going to
try and recreate this movie from what i
have how do you remember this perfectly
um because okay so as a kid in the
summer
oh this is going on another tangent now
so my summer's considered consisted of
me going to thailand and me spending
like six weeks in thailand and obviously
i wouldn't have something to do every
day so
so
like part of my childhood childhood
experience is going to the mall
and go and in like and just like in in
basically every southeast asian country
there'd be these stands where you have
these like dvd covers and you just like
you just like flip through the covers
and just choose which movies you'd want
to see and some of them weren't out on
dvd yet officially right so you just
flip through them you just want i want
that one i want that one i want that one
and one that one and then they'd ask you
to uh go go walk in the mall for like a
good half an hour to an hour and then
they'll call you i'll tell you when your
purchase is ready right which was a 100
totally legal of course of course um but
you all know there's nothing very strict
copyright yes yes yes yes um so like my
summer would just be basically watching
every
blockbuster hollywood movie that came
out that year because that that i i
looked forward to it because i could
literally pick every film through this
day knowing is still the best
and to this day i still remember knowing
that's why that's honestly why 50 first
dates almost went went on my 3x3 because
i'd watched that so many times what are
you going to say because of knowing
i was like what is this episode because
only one movie that tops no
yeah so like i've watched so many of
these films which are now what i
classify as like airplane films because
now i would not watch them in any other
circumstances unless i was on an
airplane um but of knowing was one of
the films that i was stuck inside
indoors in thailand
had nothing to do but just watch films
and uh from what i remember it was they
i think it had to do with like a time
capsule that was buried ages ago oh
right yeah that was it and there was
like a number like a cipher or something
yeah there was some kind of cipher
numbers or something that like
and that like
predicted the apocalypse or something um
that sounds dumb and nicolas cage was
just like i see the future i see what's
going to happen the number is basically
and uh
stuff nicholas cage things happen yeah
and then uh the world literally ends
because i think it's a solar flare that
uh kills everyone uh spoilers if you
ever wanted to watch knowing i wanted to
watch if if he ever wanted to watch the
masterpiece that is nicholas cage's
knowing
um
how did we get on this topic
just talking about movies
is that a horror movie i i think it is a
horror it's supposed to be a horror it's
not as it is horrible i'm looking up
right now
i'm looking at right now knowing my name
is casey can we take a break because i
need to pee and i'm very hot right now
yeah i found out it is a science fiction
film not a horror film but it was uh it
was it was it was pretty felt like
horror it was pretty horrible what ever
happened to nicolas cage i know he's
just busy kind of went off the rails in
here a little bit and then i don't know
i don't i don't feel educated enough to
talk about it but
i don't really keep up with nicholas
cage's life
i mean how many nicholas cage films have
you seen a fair amount too many too many
probably more than i'd catch i probably
watched one and i was like what all
right
you're not watching one
huh yeah i was about to say connor
i've heard of that one [ __ ] classic i
think i think i watched uh what was the
one where he was in vegas
you're in loading in life yeah if you're
in losing las vegas i watched that one
with las vegas from the time did that
have a nicholas cage in it yeah yeah
yeah that was nicholas oh yeah i had no
idea i was fearing loathing in las vegas
and i was like all right is that a
remake is that a remake
i feel like thank you
i think it is yeah yeah i watched that
and i saw his like you know the scene
where he like [ __ ] loses it in the
casino yeah oh yeah
and i was like
all right
okay
i just got like at that moment i was
like i understand nicolas cage now
and then everything else i've seen from
nicolas cage has just been like youtube
clips from other movies honestly that's
that's all you need to like experience
nicholas kidd i feel that's the best way
to experience this okay just out of
context movie clips right i think one of
my favorite youtube nicholas cage clips
is this there's a lot by the way there's
a lot but one of my favorites is just
someone edited
edited him like uh during like a driving
scene or something and it's just like
it's just
him like getting into a car and just it
out of context it looks like he's just
play driving like
it's it's so hard to describe but it's
uh it's it's
you gotta watch it and another another
thing is just nicholas cage slowly
losing his mind as well yeah well have
you ever seen no one i think sorry yeah
it's just like him slowly getting more
and more crazy as the clip goes to the
south to the um soundtrack of requiem of
dream
yeah and it's absolutely [ __ ] amazing
this one oh i gotta show you afterwards
uh
adaptation of a novel i think oh okay
okay okay it's not a remake oh yeah yeah
but uh yeah i what happened to nicolas
cage we could use more nicholas cage
films honestly
i don't know i can't remember how we got
onto the topic of nicola's case oh no i
lied i've seen that other film with the
nicholas case the the not the bees one
what the [ __ ] is that called again the
piece
what the [ __ ] is the name of that movie
i just i have not seen the bees one i've
not seen that movie but i've seen that
i've seen
i saw that i watched wikiman just
because that you know the [ __ ] not
the bees one was like it was a meme for
the longest time so i'm like well i mean
it's a funny meme but i kind of want to
see this scene in context right i just
got really curious i was like i want to
see do you need to see the scene in
context i watched it in context oh did
you what yeah
actually just as much sense out of
context honestly
it was the first time where i i watched
it
and then i instantly recognized the meme
right i was like oh this is the scene
yeah finally i'll be able to understand
why they pour the bees in the basket and
i wish i was like
no i don't know did i like
pass out for like five minutes or
something like
it just suddenly went to the scene i was
like wait i don't understand why
this is kind of unnecessary
what is that film even about i think i
don't even remember that's the only
scene i remember is the the bee scene
like every i think everybody i think
everybody who watched wikiman yeah only
remembers that the bc the b scene
honestly is there any other scene in the
movie it's just that not nothing that's
notable no nothing that's that's worth
putting to memory oh my god yeah like on
the topic of horror films one thing that
always like
fascinated me as a kid that i don't
think is around anymore is like i feel
like
part of the part of the you know the
blockbuster or rental dvd experience for
me was going to the rental like the
blockbuster and just seeing like the
[ __ ] horrific
dvd covers of like every horror movie
right i don't know why like they those
fascinated me as a kid and they're bad
or like what do you mean horrific like
scary yeah they were like really i was
terrified i was like because the
blockbuster near my house well that
that's not their anymore obviously there
was it was separated into aisles for
different genres yeah all of the action
blockbusters were in one aisle yeah all
the romance were in one hour and then
right on like the far left of the
blockbuster there was the aisle for all
the horror films yeah i was so scared to
walk down that aisle
just because like just in my periphery
you just see this like
terrifying looking movies right and yeah
usually it's got like a really scary
face yeah it's like looking right in
front i'm just like i i i i was scared
of seeing the horror titles honestly i'm
like i'm i'm kind of a [ __ ] honestly
when it comes to when it comes to films
um i'm kind of a [ __ ] when it comes i'm
a proud person i i will happily admit
that like sydney tries to get me to
watch a horror film i'm like no sydney i
am too scared okay i i think because i
had an older brother two older brothers
i think i just saw the covers laying
around a bunch because they're like they
were like you know my oldest brother was
like uh
i don't know i actually don't know how
many years older he is than me i can't i
can't keep track i can actually remember
i can actually remember the time where i
realized i hated horror films it's
because like i think i was like five or
six years old yeah and i was in the
living room and my parents were watching
the ring
and like obviously you know i was kind
of just hanging around while they were
just watching that movie but i i
remember i looked over at the tv and it
was the scene where sadoko comes out of
the tv yeah and that was the moment i
was like i hate this i i hate anything
that is like this i hate any film that
is like
blue gradient
radiance you know
the vhs is the true horror is when
you're like 14 watching a film with your
parents and a sex scene comes on oh my
god
relatable you're like
i don't know what this is what is this i
have no idea what's going on even a kiss
scene for me was like like really like
oh just no like a like a way too dragged
out kiss scene you know yeah
it's like a make-out scene yeah it
doesn't it doesn't go to the sex scene
it's just stop it's probably like a pg
film or something it's just a really
long make-out scene i'm just like guys
we get it
get a [ __ ] room all right please my
parents are here stop it no because like
i remember back back in the age of like
teen like teen comedy flicks with stuff
like american pie and stuff like that i
don't know why american pie was always
on tv in the uk yeah yeah on itv2 it was
always on yeah it was always on it was
always on at like
10 to 11 for some reason they played all
the american pie films all the time okay
it was always like everyone in the uk
has seen american pie it was always
uncut as well it was it was the closest
thing we had like to uh
when uh i was available american pie two
and of course there was like the lesbian
make-out scene oh my god and of course
that was the scene that they had to walk
through
have those movies aged well i don't
think they've aged i don't think they've
aged one at all no
yeah i haven't seen an american pilot
pie in a while i think all those kinds
of like teenage comedy films have just
not aged like like scary movie has not
aged well scary movie was never funny i
don't know i think i remember there was
less funny now yeah one time i was
watching something and it was like i
think there was drugs and sex in it and
i was just playing my game boy yeah well
this is going on they were like oh i
remember i was like 12 saying my parents
like i don't know he doesn't understand
anything and i'm like i'm like oh i
think i do i just i'm just pretending
like i'm not paying attention
did your parents ever say anything
during like those [ __ ] awkward scenes
or no that's right it was just like the
awkward side it was just silence that's
what makes it more awkward oh i always
used to like get up and like be like i
gotta go to the bathroom
yeah i did yeah i remember i was like if
one of my parents didn't do it i was
like i should say all right i'll be the
one to go to the bathroom you know what
film i remember watching at like age 10
with my parents i think this is why they
played it because i was so young where
they thought he's not gonna understand
anything yeah it was brokeback mountain
nice
like my parents okay i don't remember
what happened to it because i was 10.
but i do remember there was there was
gay things happening yeah it's just jake
gyllenhaal and heath ledger having a
water session yeah yeah i remember but
that's yeah i was like oh okay i don't
know what's i don't understand what's
happening but my parents were like for
some reason they were like yeah let's
just broke back around him with our son
it's so unfortunate though because
that's actually a really [ __ ] good
news because i went back and watched it
after i was like uh i think 18 because i
had watched the doc and i was like whoa
this heath ledger guy connect good
damn yeah and then obviously because you
found out about his death
whoa i gotta watch everything he's in
yeah and i was like wow this is good i
think i remember watching this but i
couldn't remember when and then i was
like oh
like kick flashback
i remember now
but i remember i was speaking to my
friend
and he was like
yeah do you ever just feel awkward when
sex scenes come on when you're with your
friends and i'm like no no i'm like i'm
like no not at all when you're with your
friends and stuff like what no yeah why
would i feel awkward with a sexy my
mates like then it's just weird didn't
it she said i'm like no i don't think
i've ever watched a sex scene with my
mates now i think about it
is that like a thing you have to like
check off i don't know
you never watched a film with your
friends that has a sex scene in it i'm
trying to think i think i've watched
like funny porno plots with my friends
like fake taxi with my friends i've just
watched porn with my friends
i think i think i have watched i have
been like let's watch this funny porno
you know oh yeah of course yeah yeah i
don't think i've ever gone through that
no that's like my favorite pastimes like
watching cursed porn with my friends
i had a friend as well i was like he can
watch straight uh normal movies with
straight sex in it but he couldn't watch
not normal movies with gay sex scenes in
it with his friends it's just super
uncomfortable
that's just a bit of macho insecurity
yeah
that sounds a bit insecure yeah i don't
know man sounds like you're a little
insecure he's like no no no i just don't
like it i'm like why don't you like it
and then he's like i'm not homophobic
i'm like
i don't know
what's wrong with the little guy on
guyana yeah bro
like frankly as a man i enjoy watching
other channels
i think there's nothing manlier than
being able to sit there and enjoy that
you know come on man what's wrong you
know man it's just blokes hanging out i
don't know
i feel like yeah that happens a lot of
guys like that in the uk though you know
there's always there's always one guy
like that i feel in every guy i feel i
feel like
lad's culture is definitely like a thing
in the uk which is like kind of i'll
save in australia yeah yeah do you guys
have lads culture in australia your
friends who would be like that if you
try if you're oh yeah absolutely like
you know like because i went to a boys
school as well so it was even more so
where it's like just macho and security
everywhere where you know you'd be out
yeah it's after school it's kind of
toxic yeah yeah i didn't and they'd just
be like you know a girl from like you
know a nearby girl school or whatever
yeah yeah oh you you oh you should
totally smash her bro you should totally
smash it i'm just like i'm not you know
i try to be confrontational because
they're your friends right but i also
try and i'm not going to sit there and
be like dude that's pretty you know
that's pretty not okay that's just
it's pretty it's pretty [ __ ]
i've had arguments with my friends about
it as well or i'll just be like yeah
that's uh that's kind of homophobic
but that is homophobia yeah exactly why
do you think because we spend so much
time on the internet that we've just had
like more awareness about this kind of
culture and stuff i think so because you
know a lot of my friends would never be
like they're not i don't think they
would ever be like i hate gay people or
anything like that right but also you
have to understand where that comes from
if you if there's something where you
can watch a normal sex scene but you
can't watch a gay sex scene yeah like
why is that like what's going on there
like
if you're a normal person surely who
doesn't give a [ __ ] you'd have no
problem to either right yeah you know
maybe you would find one harder than the
other but surely you wouldn't have a
problem right yeah i don't know if this
is too much for trash taste viewers
i mean like just because you're okay
with watching a sex scene doesn't mean
you need to be like into it no that's
what i like
don't have to actively dislike it but
like you don't have to like turn it off
or like go in the other room yeah you
know what i mean like there's a point
you can just sit there and be like all
right it's not for me but i'm not going
to be disgusted but it's part of the
story right yeah it's like this is what
it is yeah that's what i was saying i
was like you know if it's part of the
plot it's what it is man like they're
like oh it's just kind of weird isn't it
i'm like i'm like is it weird explain
how it's weird don't watch brokeback
mountain if that's the case
that's literally what that movie is
about i was like i was like that's the
problem though you think it's weird like
it's not like it's like it's not it's
not weird that people [ __ ] yeah
i think i think the problem is that it's
just a lot of the times especially like
in loud culture people just have never
thought about this too deeply because
that's that's like they have these they
yeah i'm not saying that someone is yeah
i totally agree with you go ahead yeah
no because like this this is what i feel
every time i go back to my hometown and
i see some like my hometown friends who
like i i very much grew up in like lads
culture hanging out with like let's
let's land
uh and they still like [ __ ] go to you
know go every every [ __ ] summer go to
ibiza and you know try to smash as many
birds as possible
it's you know that that kind of that's
what it is that's kind of like lads
culture and i'm just like
as i've grown older i'm just like this
is a kind of a toxic mindset in a lot of
ways you know it's uh it's it's very
much
uh because i think the problem is that
they don't really talk about it they
don't really talk about their don't
really talk about their feelings or like
really think about things too deeply
because yeah that's not a loud thing
it's considered weak yeah that's
considered weak yeah you're not an alpha
male if you talk about your feelings and
[ __ ] and also you know they don't really
have conversations like this yeah they
don't talk about it so normally when
i've when it's been saying that i've
spoken about people it's like
especially in like where i'm from it's
like the first person who's ever been
like now why do you feel that way about
this yeah
like
now why is it that it makes you
uncomfortable you know what i mean like
yeah so what do you mean by that yeah
yeah it's not on that and i was just
like
you know and i've had like
confrontations about it because it's
like yeah they get very defensive about
it yeah like they feel like oh [ __ ] wait
is he trying to say that i'm i'm in the
wrong for feeling this way yeah yeah and
it's like well no i'm not trying to but
it's like why are you feeling that way
maybe i think maybe you just want to
have a discussion about it maybe maybe
oh like maybe look at like what's going
on
it's funny because like some of the most
kind of insecure
feeling of people i've ever met are like
the uh like some of the like biggest
lads i've ever seen like the prop like
jim bros who
sometimes it's it's insecurity sometimes
it's it's uh it toxic masculinity
sometimes homophobia it's like it's
whatever it is it's like get to the core
of it if that's what's bothering you you
can't watch brokeback mountain without
being disgusted
that's a great movie that's a great move
all i'm saying is if you're a guy don't
be afraid to talk about your feelings
with other guys i feel like i feel like
i didn't have that when i was growing up
because i thought i thought that it was
the mentality where if i did this with
my bros then i was the weak one you know
that's that's not what that's not what
bros do to each other yeah you know and
i i wouldn't say we're like sjw or
anything like that i just i don't know i
just don't
don't want to discriminate i don't
exactly why should you you know i don't
know exactly my personal opinion i'm
sure that i'm i'm no doubt there's some
viewers of trash tastes like i can't
believe this they've spoken about this
issue and stuff but i mean that's i mean
it's a sensitive time
stuff that i would talk about yeah but i
mean there's some things that are
sensitive and there's some things where
i'm like no that's just straight up
wrong yeah
of course yeah i mean there's you know
there's some things where i'm just like
i i think we i think we should talk
about this and i think you know it's i
think
it's not toxic at all to at least start
a conversation because i think a lot of
a lot of the times a lot of people just
haven't really never really put any
thought into it and they correctly
don't yeah they grew up in a culture
they grew up in a lifestyle and that has
just never
put them in a position that challenges
the way they think yeah and if someone
does feel uncomfortable with us talking
about this topic or hearing that idea
makes you uncomfortable i would say just
like don't get angry about it don't
don't you know react to it just think
like all right just turn off trash taste
go watch no no no
just think why does it like why does it
get you angry like what about it like if
that's like a whole religious thing all
right fine that's that's that's your
problem about like i don't know like
yeah i cuz like i just feel like
it's it's better now for at least people
who are like i guess on the internet and
especially on social media because
people are talking about this more often
yeah which is good but i still like
they're they're
you forget sometimes that
we are not i i don't even know if we're
the majority you know because you like
every time i go home i don't know
it's hard to tell because we're i'm like
so ingrained in obviously our jobs are
surrounded with the internet and
surrounded with you know people who
think like me yeah that i it's weird
whenever you go to like go back home see
family
see friends from back home and you're
just like wow everyone thinks exactly
the same everyone has not changed much
at all because they just there's no one
in their community or in this group of
friends that are exposed to the same
thing as we are so yeah no totally yeah
because obviously on my channel like
very pro-lgbtq but like
obviously going back home it's not a
thing that's spoken about much it is
kind of it depends who you ask really i
think now more than before definitely
yeah with how the world's just changing
right yeah my parents pretty good with
it i i always try to educate when i can
try and tell them about it yeah like i i
would like to think most of the time it
is just pure ignorance and oh totally
especially in small towns yeah
you know obviously not everyone is on
the internet all the time everyone's in
a big city you surrounded so it's you
know a lot of the time they just don't
come across it they're just like oh it's
a that guy's very funny on tv and he's
gay
really
that's what it's like that's what my
parents are
but i mean you know it's uh
it's it's i mean it's everywhere right
now so it's like it's good yeah yeah i
just iron him it's uh it sucks that it's
one of those things that it even has to
be somewhat controversial
to talk about right and we've already
spoke about trash taste i'm sure that
some people will be alienated by it but
it sucks that even has to be something
that alienates people yeah you know when
it should affect people are gay get over
it
[Laughter]
you sometimes forget heath leisure is a
[ __ ] australian in that movie is he
australian
oh okay yeah do you think he's british
i think a lot of people think he's
british i have no idea i think everyone
thinks he's american oh dude yeah i
thought he was american because i my
first experience with heath ledger was
uh 10
just great actor yeah fine
but yeah i feel like a lot of you know
if you're in hollywood i think we've
talked about this haven't we how they're
good at like
they're gonna doing the american accent
but uh you you watch like some of like
the worst the worst attempts that people
are attempting a british accent it's
like comically bad oh yeah i love keanu
reeves but it's british accident oh him
in like dracula dracula yeah that was
so bad
that was hilarious it's a tie between
that and uh [ __ ] at the end of django
when tarantino appears and it's like an
australian oh my god
what's going on
on the inside when i saw that i was like
this movie was almost perfect and then
i'm like i'm glad he blew up
at the end someone needed to get rid of
that
[Music]
actually i'm sitting here like what are
we titled this episode
yeah right what we even spoke about
today i don't know how do we even get
onto this oh the summer is hot
the summer is hot summer block
trash tastes summer blockbuster
[ __ ] no
i love how uh like during the
conversation earlier about whatever the
[ __ ] it was just i i was trying to
listen to what you were saying but just
from the outside i could just hear like
a shitload of cicadas
cicadas yeah cicadas cicadas cicada
i say cicadas isn't it cicadas is it
am i the weird one i say
cicada okay google how do you pronounce
cicadas
sorry to anyone who is [ __ ] uh
probably just like we got two with a
podcast do we find us out what does
people say
cicada
yeah does that say american or uk what
is that what's good
[Applause]
well the thing is that we don't have
them in my life my life is a lie
my life is a [ __ ] lie lord cicada has
been one of those i should say chicago
cicada is one of those words i've only
ever been here heard
americans say yes because we don't have
it in the uk no one says it in the uk
sure
i've never heard that any british person
they said it literally sounds like
something out of harry potter no it's
cicada
have you ever heard a british person say
cicada no i have never heard a british
person say i'm saying now i'm getting it
in my head now yeah i know it's like
it's like you have to rewind that right
now i remember because
we literally we literally had a netflix
shoot uh where we had to talk about like
summer anime things i put zakat
i thought cicada or cicada was spelt
c-i-r-c-a-d
yeah he literally wrote sir
sir
and i did and i didn't know you got
[ __ ]
[Music]
yeah i thought cicada had a r in it this
entire time and apparently it doesn't
um it's cicada now yeah but yeah i mean
i've said this before they never fix you
but i remember when i first moved japan
and i literally had gone my entire life
thinking that every cicada sound effect
in every anime was just a stock sound
effect right because they all sound
exactly the same you watch like one
summer anime episode and you're like
they're just using the same [ __ ]
sound effect as the other anime right
and i didn't realize until i moved to
japan that
cicadas just all sound exactly the
[ __ ] same yeah i thought it was just
a [ __ ] audio jungle stock sound
effects no
i don't know how they sound so similar
it's literally just been hardwired into
their brain to be like
sound like this at this exact interval
yeah to the point where i was like
sitting at home one night um or one day
and i literally thought i had the tv on
playing a random anime and i didn't
realize that just the window was open
yeah i literally like went to my living
room to turn off the tv because i was
like i'm not no one's watching anything
and
lo and behold it was just the window and
i couldn't tell the difference between a
tv stock sound effect and the real life
yeah
man
have you seen them flying yeah they're
[ __ ] massive they're terrifying yeah
i was outside uh the trash taste office
and uh i was just walking listening to
music just jamming you know and one flew
in my [ __ ] face and i [ __ ] smacked
it
i smacked it and i felt really bad cause
it hit the woman in front of me on her
and her back
you literally just tossed this
yeah and she turned around i was like
[ __ ] [ __ ] playing ping pong yeah i
just hit it i
what's scarier is when they land on your
balcony but like like they don't say but
you think they're dead they just don't
move yeah they just like kind of pop and
just flop down you're like oh is he dead
and then you touch it's like
yeah there's one outside my door so i
opened the door yeah and then
what is that
scarier than any horror film because i
just opened my door you don't expect
that yeah there's nothing in my door you
never expect a jump scare at your door
that's [ __ ] up
i'm gonna use the last of last of my
life to troll this huge it was literally
like under the door so i opened the door
and it was just it got like
the door like like rubbed it or
something and you're like
what is that i've never seen one before
either no i've never seen one this is my
first time i had never seen one before
either so i had no idea what they look
like and these [ __ ] [ __ ] are so
big yeah they're [ __ ] masculine
they're [ __ ] back in my like
apartment
they're terrified also another thing i
didn't know is that like i had always
assumed i remember the first time i came
to japan like these [ __ ] are
loud like yeah like like you you need to
wear you need like noise casting
headphones to like even survive outside
you think it's like a swarm of them yeah
i thought i walked past this tree and
i'm like man these there are like a
swarm of cicadas just in this tree and
then it's like it just like suddenly
just stops and i'm like what's going on
and then i i realized it's one
[ __ ] making all this sound yeah
one [ __ ] makes so it's so loud
and it's actually like impressive how
[ __ ] loud this cicada is yeah right
because i
i'm on my balcony and like i can hear
what i think is a swarm of cicadas on
like the other side of the city or
something and then i realized just one
because it just like it's so weird like
having like a like it's so weird going
outside and just hearing like a [ __ ]
noise like it sounds like an alarm yeah
it just suddenly stops as well and then
it just suddenly stops
why why do they make noise what are they
trying to this on a mate or something
yeah yeah yeah
[ __ ] say why are they i think they're
like don't they like rub their legs
together to make that sound or something
i think it's like a violin yeah like
yeah
like the world's shittiest violin
yeah cause apparently they can only mate
during like a very short period of their
life
um during the summer yeah during the
summer so they're like
they're [ __ ] horny as [ __ ] man they
need to [ __ ] they're the lads of the
insects yeah yeah and then they [ __ ]
once and they die and then that's it
that's just their entire life they they
live for that one [ __ ] and then they die
make as much noise as possible
i came too early died
[Laughter]
honestly i can think of worse ways to
die yeah than having like a not so
amazing that you're like all right life
is peaked now i am
death initially some people die from
cows you know that's for [ __ ] sake
i'm bringing this back right because
after that i i realized god was like how
do people die from cows i'm like god
they're like four tons what do you mean
how do people die from cows like so many
people in the suburbs
yeah you can die from cows but you can
die from anything that's like four
[ __ ] tons from any like heavy animals
that's why should not make me look like
an idiot for saying a cow can kill you a
cow [ __ ] kill you
just because a cow can kill you doesn't
mean that you know probably if you get
killed by a cow you're doing something
stupid right yeah that's just that's
just my opinion right you'd have to try
really [ __ ] hard to die from a cow
most most ways people die are from
stupid ways god as well
believe it or not i remember a statistic
in japan where it's like more people in
japan die from vending machines and they
do shark attacks oh well yeah that makes
sense yeah right how from shaking the
vending machine and landing on you and
dying okay well that's just idiots being
idiots you deserve that if you're sure
that's what i mean it's the same thing
with a cow like you're not gonna be
walking through the [ __ ] panic and
then suddenly cow's like let me come and
squish you
also very very i think they can bite you
at all oh yeah um
if you're strong enough to uh push a
vending machine on yourself yeah why are
you wasting all that talent you know
what i mean like how do you get the
vending machine to fall on you it can't
be easy do you jump on it like why are
people doing this i i don't know
you cannot you have you tried moving a
vending machine it is not easy
like you really have to be committed to
this stupid act like you really are
admitting like all right i'm breaking a
sweat today like this is how i'm gonna
take it off the yeezys for this one
that's what i'm saying about dying dying
from cows you know why why why [ __ ]
try push like lying under a cow
or just like i'm standing behind a couch
just go swim in shark infested water
apparently i think you you know i think
you've more chance of dying via the the
cow honestly um have you ever seen
enough live league videos people [ __ ]
with animals to realize
watch live link i don't know you just
just casually sit down and watch live no
but sometimes i think i'd rather watch a
horror film on facebook or twitter and
one gets on there somehow and you just
how i don't know i'm just happy i'm a
widow yeah you just see like uh you know
like a monkey punching a man or
something i don't know what
what wait what
sure he does retweet some of those
questions she just sees [ __ ] and then
like people like [ __ ] around with
monkeys and then the monkey just beats
them up
honestly like if i see the live link
logo that's like a i should probably
there is a worrying amount of people who
think that like they can just like do
whatever they want their animals
yeah
but it's normally like like third world
countries and it's like scary because
they're like [ __ ] with like a monkey
and then the monkey just beats them up
and you're like well i mean fair enough
what did you expect yeah you kind of had
the right you know in court i would i
would i would fight anderson you know
you're likely [ __ ] with the smartest
animal yeah like because like i'm very
wary whenever i see anything live like
because i've seen enough [ __ ] up [ __ ]
on the inside it's also a meme i've seen
people put live league on them like meme
stars
so now i'm like i'm not sure if it's
meme or not it's it's like playing games
like reddit 5050 or whatever it's called
right that's the only that's the only
time i've seen enough lively tower where
i'm just like yeah no nothing good comes
out of live sometimes it comes on and
you're like this is intriguing enough
where i don't think i can stop watching
now like the the premise i'm hooked i
don't know man i very quickly pulled
them yeah i'm just like you guys have
more willpower than me
when i see the premise or the first one
second the video i'm like damn i can't
turn it off now
is that wrong with me i feel like that's
bad i mean
i'm i'm just wired to click bait i don't
know
monkey brain activates right your
curiosity
is you spelling uh circada incorrectly
yeah circada i realized like the other
day i'm like [ __ ] i can't spell [ __ ]
without autocorrect anymore
my spelling is so bad without
autocorrect yeah that's pretty much
something i realize now when it's not on
i just kind of like type [ __ ] and i know
that it will fix it for me
i just type fast
yeah
yeah i mean i i'm i got something
similar as well where i'm like i can't
do mental arithmetic anymore like i i
literally like what like i'm just like
oh what's uh nine times eight and i'm
just like
get out the calculator
like i'm so reliant i should do it but
it'll take me yeah 20 seconds i can do
it but it requires thinking and i don't
i i'm not all
[Music]
there you go okay i had to think about
it
graduating masters in engineering by the
way yeah
what was your method of getting that
i
don't
because the nine times table is the
easiest yeah that's what i would i would
the nine times nine is 81 then just
minus eight
that that's that's way too complicated
even if there's an even easier
anything times nine is super [ __ ]
easy i should have done that i don't
know no i mean i i don't really have a
system it's just figuring whatever your
brain is wired to do fast right yeah
well for me if it's nine times eight
then it's like well eight is so it
starts with a seven because whatever
you're timing by nine is always one
digit below yeah and then the two digits
uh sums up to nine am i i never
understood you know how every time you
would ever have like a new math teacher
they would always teach you that weird
way of solving a plus and a minus yeah
yeah i mean and they're like right so
we're gonna add 425 to uh 522 and then
they're going to do right so we're going
to add the four to the five easy it's
great that now you know i'm like
do you really need to write this down
can we just like can we just
and then there's always like the like
just the really obscure ways to do it as
well where it's like there's got to be
an easier way yeah yeah all right
all right so when you bring the one over
pull out your dictionary yeah or it
would be like dividing by and they would
have this weird ass timetable or
something to do it and i'm like this
feels so convoluted why don't why not
just like figure out some other methods
like teacher when am i ever going to
divide 973 by 67 like i'm not i'm never
going to i'm never going to go and count
down i don't need to know this [ __ ]
every every single like yeah like it is
great that you if you can do that with
your with your mind but there's a party
trick there's absolutely no setting
where you are ever not going to be using
a calculator and even if you are they
will not allow you to do that because
they won't trust you you should be using
a calculator for good practice
even if you could divide yeah yeah
insane numbers that people like no
that's not it it's good for like
estimates when you're talking
engineering terms you're like okay well
could maybe you try this much no i don't
think they just just off the top of my
head that doesn't seem right yeah yeah
yeah that's good but in general like you
know those exams you know it's just
funny how like mental arithmetic has
just become become kind of like a party
trick yeah like you there's there's
always like you always see that one guy
every so often where you get the you get
like the bill and they can just like
divide exactly the right amount in their
head yeah but but it's also like the
shittiest type of party trick because
it's the party trick that you do and
nobody believes
and people check it anywhere either way
it's like nah let me put the calculator
out
oh it
numbers now that is just my life but yes
exactly the same spelling now where i
just i could not live without
autocorrect and i don't know i feel like
it's it's do you have those words that
you just you you know what they look
like but you're like i just can't bother
to learn how to spell it right you know
what i mean i just want necessary i was
literally about to say that
that is the one where i'm like i
honestly cannot remember which is the
two seas 2s yeah i just typed two s's
right
i don't know i just got no i'm pretty
sure the one for me that always [ __ ] me
up that i still never get right is
guaranteed yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah i
was like is the u in there is there an a
in this is it guaranteed or is it
guaranteed
this is what i just i don't care i
haven't like yeah
necessarily i'm just like i'm pretty
sure it's two s's
no it's not is it it's two s's i don't
know maybe it is
yeah
n-e-c-e-s-s-a-r-y right yeah i'm pretty
sure it is but yeah i already hold on
let me check
i'll never get out of the autocorrect i
just type and then click yeah it's that
one yeah
but i think the thing about spelling is
that it doesn't
at the end of the day spelling is
irrelevant
at the end of the day you know you can
spell word wrong and people will still
get like the meaning of the word most of
the time right
isn't there this phonetics yeah i mean
haven't you seen like the video where if
you put the first letter right and the
last letter right you just mixed it up
on the internet i've seen that yeah it's
like you've seen the ballerina that
spins the other way too gone
have you seen the dress that's blue and
green gold oh yeah
i remember that oh my god i completely
forgot about that the internet was on
fire for a week unnecessarily over a
[ __ ] dress i remember meme culture
but i remember that was like the hot
thing back then back in the day
um
i knew i knew that dress meme went too
far when people were like all right so i
went into photoshop and i got the color
drop
and i can confirm the hex digits that it
is in fact blue and gold what wasn't
there that like audio
kind of yeah yeah
yeah that one oh yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah i remember that
i just saw that i was like who cares
yeah i i felt like after the whole dress
debacle it felt like everyone was
looking for the next thing that everyone
would
interpret differently interpret
differently and i just didn't give a
[ __ ] that was a nice meme that lasted
three days yeah i remember like the only
what what they called the
audio
i'm like audio illusion audio illusion
that's the it's actually it's not really
an audio illusion it's just did you ever
did you guys ever do like the uh
frequency test where you have to like
test your frequency
and um
like i remember i was fancy i remember
my frequency was like so [ __ ] good as
a kid and i thought i'm never gonna lose
this
i don't know like dude as a kid do you
ever did you ever get that point where
i grown up told you that this is gonna
happen to you when you grow up yeah and
as a kid you're just like that's never
going to happen to me it's never going
to [ __ ] happen to me
i remember the first time i felt old was
the first time i did the second time i
did did a frequency test when i was like
mid-20s and i'm just like this isn't the
same number as i remember as a kid
the grown-ups are right i'm getting old
wait wait so is the frequency test like
the how much you can hear is that the
one yeah so like the better your hearing
is the higher the frequency oh yeah yeah
yeah generally when you get around to 30
it starts to get a lot worse yeah yeah
yeah i mean doesn't like who the [ __ ]
needs to hear like the
high kilohertz i mean i i immediately
felt that like because you know in like
some arcades in japan no yeah i like
that keto tone that like stops like uh
animals from coming into oh yeah yeah
and
every time we walk past like an arcade
with like a bunch of friends they'll be
like oh [ __ ] i'll be like what
i legitimately don't it's that it's
actually an advantage here yeah right
yeah because sydney sydney can hear it
and i can't anymore yeah right yeah yeah
apparently it hurts i'm just like i
don't know apparently like in a lot of
shops in japan they just play this like
i can't describe it i think isn't it you
could like
stop
teenagers i've also heard it's to stop
birds from flying cats and cats okay can
you hear a connor yeah i can hear it
okay what does it sound like i was gonna
describe what it was and i realized i've
never been here
i just realized i've never heard of an
uncomfortable ring in your ears
is that if they've just put this high
frequency alarm or ring to stop
birds mosquitoes animals and loitering
oh okay
i don't know which one it's actually for
might be is it for humans or animals i
don't know apparently it's for both
because you can hear it as well
probably should have picked a lower
frequency though because it doesn't work
if you've just got [ __ ] hearing then you
just immune to it like well it's funny
to stop like kids
okay
okay okay that's uh
i've never been able to hear it though
even even when i was a kid yeah but
you've been listening to like music for
yeah
yeah i think there's so many concerts
where my ears just got [ __ ] you're
gonna be like 14 what why are you saying
to me god i'm still like that yeah yeah
true you are your hearing is really bad
yeah
no but i talked about on the podcast
remember i was like because when we went
to go do the health checkup and i got an
a for my hearing and then i realized oh
i don't have bad hearing i just don't
listen
you're just [ __ ] dumb yeah i just i
just don't care about what you're saying
sometimes but i just shut it out true
true that's what it is yeah boys have
any fun plans for the summer
you know what i miss
um this is like the first time in my
life where i've just not lived near a
body of water
like you're surrounded by water what do
you mean we're literally an island
country no but like we're we're in tow
we're in tokyo right yeah and i think
the closest thing is like tokyo bay yeah
like part of part of the summer
experience for me is just going to the
beach somewhere and just like having it
having a nice chill
you know beer or something and haven't
been able to do that for the past two
years and i've really i've really missed
that experience i mean it doesn't really
matter because like the beaches have
been closed no exactly it doesn't matter
anyway because i can't go to the beaches
anyway yeah like okinawa's on the
lockdown so i can't go there so just i
just doesn't feel like i've i've had the
worst part of the summer experience
which is just the [ __ ] blistering
heat and haven't been able to just enjoy
the nice trapped in a concrete jungle
all right yeah basically so what are you
going to do for your summer then go on
i don't know what can i do for the
summer is there anything fun you can do
in the summer that doesn't involve a
beach or a pool or any body of water
stay inside play video games that sounds
pretty pretty [ __ ] good
that's what you do in winter though
right both seasons both seasons all
seasons
because uh another thing is that uh we
get mosquitoes here in japan and we
don't
yeah we do oh yeah yes
do you not get bitten no
lucky i never get them
how would you not get [ __ ] i get eaten
alive
maybe my blood doesn't taste good i
don't know i've never had a mosquito
apparently it does depend on your blood
type okay i think it does because i get
bitten to [ __ ] whenever mosquitoes
i know i can be in an area where someone
will get bit in a ton i won't have any
on me i literally like god always tells
me yeah i literally laid outside on my
balcony for like half an hour came
inside and i had like 10 bites on my
back
i'm not even joking
don't we just don't have any bugs that
are annoying because well you guys are
mosquitos no
do you not remember when we were just
chilling out in england in my garden i
just thought i got lucky
[Laughter]
i just thought like oh this is a
stronger this is stronger blood type
somewhere in the vicinity that they're
going there's no mosquitoes no i'm just
that guy because like i'm just that guy
who like
i'm i'm the bait right because is that
meme of like the blades falling down and
the guy covering yeah it's gone everyone
else everyone else at the party yeah
cause like if people hang out with me in
thailand or japan or whatever they get
bitten less because i'm there i'm the
bait i i am what every mosquito goes
towards and i don't know why
because because in thailand we have we
have this saying where um normally it's
the mosquitoes go for the foreign people
because it's the foreign people who have
the sweet blood because the mosquitoes
aren't used to their blood so that was
it
so that was the [ __ ] life well
technically i didn't grow up in thailand
so maybe there's some kind of truth to
it but apparently apparently if you have
never been beat well if mosquitoes are
beaten by a mosquito is [ __ ] you know
what's going on huh
coming to our neighborhood
i've never i've never get bitten by
mosquitoes i'm so [ __ ] dude is it
like a blood type thing i don't even
know apparently it's like a blood type
thing it's also like a skin thing as
well like certain skin like if you have
like oily skin you're more likely to get
bitten like that i don't know there's
lots of theories out there i i think
it's literally just like if you're
unlucky you're unlucky kind of thing
yeah pretty much beer
oh yeah no apparently if you're you get
uh you're more likely to get stung if
you're drunk
is that true yeah apparently the
mosquitoes drunk i don't know that's
probably why they're like um guys come
time for a sesh right because they get
drunk in the blood right
baby
drinking so i don't know what's going on
is there a reason why mosquitoes go for
people more or less yeah it's like
there's like seven reasons yeah
i don't know if any of that has actually
been like scientifically confirmed i
feel it's just like it might be like a
little like coincidence it's not tasty
enough what the [ __ ] like what are they
like tasting
as well that's probably what i'm not
tasty bro what i want to be tasty
you don't want to be tasty missing out i
want to be tasty that's [ __ ]
mosquitoes are [ __ ] they're the worst
they're the
nobody likes mosquitoes people they
could be like the biggest animal lover
in the world and they see a mosquito and
like [ __ ] that little [ __ ] isn't like
the mosquito i think i read somewhere
isn't the mosquito like the only animal
in like the food chain where if you got
rid of them it just wouldn't change the
food chain
i don't know if that's an urban legend
but i hope it's true i think it's
something like that because i remember
saying because like i think i looked it
up because i was like because in
australia we have a [ __ ] ton of flies
yeah yeah during the summer right like
it's [ __ ] horrible especially if
you're like out in the desert yeah
nothing but flies it's disgusting and i
think i just thought to myself like man
i really just wish all flies just
disappeared and then one of my friends
was like oh no like flies are like
really important to the food chain yeah
like there's a lot of animals that eat
flies and that's all like yeah is there
an animal where if we just
it just disappeared one day
would the food change still be intact
and i think mosquitoes was one of the
humans probably oh yeah
[Laughter]
we were the
mosquitoes are [ __ ] useless things
because i mean they just [ __ ] carry
diseases right like that's all they
really do yeah they all they do is like
give malaria to people right
there's probably like one other thing
there's probably one like really obscure
species of spider or something that
could only feed on mosquitoes that would
die out that's like integral for the
food chain
it's always like that like no no this is
one animal that specifically eats this
thing yeah how would you even eradicate
mosquitoes i would even go about that
i don't know i don't ask the aussie they
[ __ ] they've they've had like enough
problems trying to eradicate a certain
like the yeah toads right yeah yeah so
we had so we had the we have a lot of
sugar cane in australia uh yeah during
like the 1800s and then cane flies were
introduced which are these specific
breed of flies that only eat ca sugar
cane and which completely wiped out a
sugar cane
and we're like well [ __ ] we gotta get
rid of these flies because our food is
getting [ __ ] up yeah and then someone
was like i've heard overseas there was a
specific type of toad called the cane
toad that specifically only eats cane
flies
someone thought oh that's brilliant
that's gonna solve all of our problems
let's introduce it so they introduced it
yeah all the cane flies disappeared but
then somebody realized
[ __ ] nothing eats cane toads
and they're literally poisonous and
they're killing our native animals
so now we just have a cane toad outbreak
and you just can't get rid of it and we
just can't get rid of them dude it's
like me playing chess they like suddenly
thought one move ahead they were like
they didn't plan anything else like this
feels like a vast oversight in like
possible downsides yeah there's no pros
and cons list someone was like bro my
mate's got one bring it over yeah let's
just test it out sounds like the
beginning of like an always sunny skit
right
like you you're just like oh let's bring
over the cane toads and you just hit you
just see like the [ __ ] intro intro
title gang choices gang introduces cane
toads to the to the food chain
but then again australia hasn't had very
much luck with uh animals i mean we had
an emu war we lost yeah i'm like what
what the [ __ ] is that about like i i
hear every australian say that and i'm
just like that just sounds like i said
the great emu awards are the dumbest
[ __ ] ever yeah they went to war against
and they lost and we lost
okay do you want to explain that dude
have you seen anemu no they're [ __ ]
terrifying can they kill you yeah
it's australia everything can kill you
you should have known that one yeah
were they eating crops they're ruining
crops yeah they were ruining crops uh
and and again like they kind of just
like over bred themselves to the point
where there was just a [ __ ] ton of emus
and just not enough space so they
started invading farmland obviously
farmers got pissed off about it so they
tried to
get them out of it but obviously it's
one man versus a [ __ ] two and a half
meter bird
that can literally just kick you in the
chest and kill you
so uh i think it went on for like
a month or something i don't know how
long it was it was a very short bit it
was a very short they wasted so much
money and like ammunition and time
ammunition yeah yeah they were shooting
them shooting them they're like trying
to gun them down yeah but they could bet
like but the emus were literally like
the spartans and they were like because
they would think it was like we we were
like xerxes army and the emus were the
spartans and they're like oh [ __ ]
because they would like they weren't
fighting them but they were just they
just kept getting away yeah it was like
a looney tunes
they couldn't they couldn't kill them
it's just like the benny hill theme for
later mom straight they they had to wait
and ambush them that's how they
see it because they travel in flock
they go together in flocks and they were
trying to ambush them and they're also
extremely fun they can run like 60 70
now the moment they started opening fire
on them they just ran away and they
would only kill like you know like
maybe yeah but they wasted like a
hundred grand in ammo like ammo isn't
cheap i feel like because we're so used
to war you think the ammo is like
affordable yeah like ammo is super
expensive yeah so they were just wasting
hundreds of thousands of dollars on
bullets especially when that war was
happening as well as probably even more
expensive and then one day someone was
like
yeah it's not worth it is it no it's
wave the white flag and then they just
retreated and it was embarrassing
so
they just failed miserably
what is going on in australia i'm sure
everyone who's like watched internet
videos has heard about this yeah like
this is a very internet video topic that
sounds like an internet historian skit
you know like yeah surprise he hasn't
made a video on it yet to be honest it's
great material
yeah i mean it's it sounds like on the
same level as like you know the 4chan
tumblr wars or something like
it just doesn't sound like it really has
just feels like the the laziest strategy
of killing them you know like there were
people who knew there were people who
died as well during the great evening
walk i feel like nobody thought this
plan through like surely there was a
better way of getting them you know what
i mean like that's what pisses me off
most it was the laziest solution they're
like firing squad and they were like
yeah okay like nobody thought is this
really the best idea you know yeah no
probably because someone probably took
one look at the [ __ ] shotgun they had
and they were like we got this
easy double
we need a [ __ ] hollywood breakdown on
this you know where where's the
hollywood summer blockbuster of the
australian emu war come on come on come
on hollywood get it together there's a
story line there man versus
should have carpets zack snyder come on
this is this is the next black slider
film
it's like a 300 spin off
that's like planet the apes from the
perspective of the emu so yeah
yeah one of them is voiced by uh
raymond from everyone loves raymond get
back nicholas cage come on yeah nicholas
cage is what is the is the main role
rate and the supporting role is ringing
he goes insane as the eevees win
there's a part where raymond dies
you know he gets shot and then
freaking his mind yeah he's freaking out
i can't go on
but he has to
oh my god and ends with the climatic
scene where they run what's the what's
the summer experience in australia
because like australia it's like winter
there christmas yeah christmas
like i always hear about like it's
summer it's like winter on australia but
like what is winter for australia is it
actually cold or do you just do you like
swap them do you just refer to winter
like hot summer is winter
no like july it's july july is the
coldest time of year in australia but is
it winter it's july winter it depends
where you are so in sydney it doesn't
get cold enough to snow
but if you drive for like two hours into
canberra it snows like a [ __ ]
i've been always under the impression of
the temperature that winter is the time
of year like winter is always november
to january
sorry november to february february yeah
i guess that is winter is it the same in
australia where you would refer to that
period of winter no that's summer
but everyone else around the hottest the
hottest time of the the hottest day of
any year is always uh new year's eve but
i always thought that it was like okay
no matter what country you're in this is
winter yeah that's what that's what i
thought it was winter it doesn't matter
the temperature what are you talking
about
because winter is the coldest time of
year for us that's
may to august yeah i know i just thought
that winter as a concept was a time
period not the season now it's
definitely a season for us um because
like at least from my memory the hottest
day of any year is always the last day
of the year right so i i used to our
family always used to go to that one
maids place who had that giant swimming
pool in his backyard because
you're in that pool till about two in
the morning because it's so [ __ ] hot
i remember the hottest experience i've
ever had in my life it was new year's
eve yeah it was 45 degrees
all right obviously 45 degrees
everyone's in the pool even after the
sun went down it was like 41 degrees
yeah and it was so hot that i remember i
went home like that morning it was like
5 a.m and the fridge had just exploded
from the heat like the fridge just
stopped working bro the fridge was like
all right guys i'm out yeah have a nice
day just life
happy new year
my final message to the world yeah so i
remember my parents got super pissed off
because they just like
literally first day of the year they
went to the electronics store and bought
a new fridge because it just it just
got busted from the heat
fridge is one of those appliances though
that i'd be excited to get a new one i'd
be like wow we can really mix it up with
the fridge this time well yeah but like
you know i think it's good when you can
buy a fridge on your own accord right i
disagree i prefer when my appliances
break
because i'm like oh i have to spend
money oh there's no oh whoa i guess i
have to get the most expensive one geez
when you're upgrading you're like oh
[ __ ] i've got a perfectly good one
i don't really need oh you start to
starve with a cockroach fridge a washing
machine or whatever or whatever it is
because it was a good appliance your
standard of an upgrade it's quite long
yeah
it's like
from
from cockroaches to no cockroaches
there's some appliances where i'm like
it does it literally doesn't need
anything fancy like a microwave does not
need to be fancy no microwave just heats
he heats thing up good thank you it
literally vibrates more water molecules
literally how would you do that
differently because i'm using joey's old
one yeah um because joey just gave me
his one because he wanted to get an uh
microwave oven microwave oven which i i
don't believe in i think that's nonsense
yeah i got the kettle from joey because
cause
when did joey give you the microwave was
it when you moved here why are you guys
like taking my hand me down it's not
because because you were like do you
want a microwave and i was like sure
because because i remember when because
this was literally in the first week
when we moved here and we were just like
settling in whatever and uh you were
just like oh do you want a kettle we
gotta you you can have a free kettle
yeah no no they were making it out to be
like a gift yeah yeah yeah back off this
is not a gift yeah i know this is
knowledgeable i remember thinking of the
time oh my god such good mate here is
he's just he's just helping me like he
just helped me give me helping me like
decorate the house
i was using those older sibling skills
yeah because i remember it was like he
was like do you want to just take the
microwave i was like why would i why
were you saying that why would i just
take the microwave and they're like oh
would you see like a gift and i'm like
some [ __ ] gear yeah
a new one yeah i'll take it but don't
don't preface that it's again because we
were gonna buy an oven
yeah yeah yeah and then we realized oh
it's it's not just an oven it's a
microwave yeah i remember the accuracy
cause like now i'm not a gift because
now living in japan i know getting rid
of appliances is a [ __ ] nightmare
it's a [ __ ] nightmare so i'm just
like that [ __ ] just wanted to
get rid of his appliances that he wanted
to replace you and he framed it as a
[ __ ] gift yeah so the person welcome
to japan
he's the kettle i don't know okay here
you go i'm such a good mayor i'm giving
you i'm literally giving you free fresh
you like kettles right yeah
i do i do
i actually don't use my kettle anymore i
use the the hot hot pot thing oh like
thermos pot whatever it's called
well you put like two liters of water in
a pot and it keeps it boiling the whole
thing oh yeah
it's more energy efficient
fancy but yeah in japan if you want to
get rid of your appliances this is
something that you should definitely be
aware of oh it's the worst um because if
it's
over like a if it's a big appliance so
like i think a hair dryer or bigger is
considered as a big appliance right
you have to call it
so literally any applause you have to
call up the
local government in your area and tell
them you want to get rid of it and then
you've scheduled it right i i actually
just finished doing that the other day
because we had to get rid of our old
dining table and our old like cabinet
that had all of our dishes in it because
yeah wait why didn't your old moving
company do it oh yeah the movie company
here
uh we just kind of forgot it oh yeah we
just kind of because i thought i
originally wanted to i originally had
the old kitchen table that we have yeah
on my balcony because i thought oh i
could use this if i'm like barbecuing or
doing something outside and i need
something to like place it on yeah but
then i kind of didn't use it it got hit
in the rain i forgot to put like a
lacquer on it so i just started rotting
and i was like all right
i need to get rid of this now and it was
oh my god dining tables do that if you
put them outside yeah yeah so uh but
it's it's cool though because in my area
that you can like register it through
like line oh that's cool but
the sucky thing is had to wait about i
don't know four weeks to throw it out
because they were like oh you have to
schedule it ahead of time and i'm like
oh okay maybe it's like always the third
thing it's like you know next week or
like this weekend or something you know
whatever it's like so uh yeah uh the
next open slot is uh 40 days from now
and you have to give them the precise
measurements of the thing yeah as well
which is i mean it's obviously i
understand why but it's one of the
things where it's like this is a hassle
that i've never had to do in the uk
before yeah so why am i measuring
something that i'm about to throw out it
yeah i made sure the moving company that
i've hired at the moment for my place
i'm like you thought of things away
right
you throw them away you think about the
like things like fridges or like washing
machines and stuff like that is that
like there's usually a service where
when they bring the new one they take
away the old yeah that's true that's
true like we just got a new washing
machine and they take away the oil and
they take away the oils like oh thank
god yeah yeah that's why you know
whoever sold you the [ __ ] cockroach
they were just like man they [ __ ]
they were like 500 iq we got him to pay
for this [ __ ]
we got him to pay for this i got scammed
that was a scam there you go
first time in japan
i got a gift
welcome to japan what a warm greeting to
a foreign country
but yeah no i made sure the movie
company was like you you've thrown
things away right yeah yeah i was like
great
everything needs to go every get rid of
everything i'm literally throwing away
like nearly everything i own
because i'm like it's all it's time for
an upgrade because i'm like yeah because
my bed was like 200 bucks for like the
bed and the mattress it's [ __ ]
terrible yeah it's like uh i'm sure like
you know prisoners in isolation get
better beds than what i've got so i was
like you know i'm get rid of it
yeah they get a whole padded room but
it's an absolute it's absolute nightmare
right because yeah i do yeah yeah people
get the whole soundproofing yeah yeah so
uh because if you want to do like myself
i have to disassemble the bed
and then like put it down yeah into the
thing schedule when they're gonna come
get it and then kind of like
schedule getting a new bed myself in
between the day i'm throwing it out it's
a real nightmare yeah yeah that was that
was a nightmare for us and that's why
like when we moved into our new place
because we threw the bed our old bed
away yeah yeah when we were waiting for
the new bed we had to sleep on like a
[ __ ] blow up mattress for like a week
oh wow just because the timing was off
yeah but like yeah cause i'm thinking
like get rid of my desk in my place oh
because you're thinking about getting in
there
well i'm just dreading having to like
schedule a [ __ ] i have to wait another
month to like throw this thing out and
then i have to take it down myself and
disassemble it i'm just like oh
yeah it's pain in the ass yeah it sucks
please please make it better you can get
a service right that's why i'm thinking
i'm just gonna like i'm just going to
pay the money just get someone to just
come and get rid of them because it
takes some if you want to get rid of
your appliances it's probably going to
take like all day just to sort out
yeah i mean if you can make you know
it's probably what an hour to
disassemble then you've got to [ __ ]
around with the calling the people yeah
taking it down figuring out when you've
got to do all that stuff like it's
probably what three hours of work yeah
you could probably make more than the
money it would cost to do that yeah yeah
so it's like definitely i would rather
because i also don't it's sometimes not
even the money it's like i don't want to
deal with this stress like this is a
stressful thing that i don't like
dealing with yeah and so i will pay a
premium to not have to do that not only
that but like i have to deal with it in
this weather yeah as well it's like [ __ ]
that disassembling that dining table in
this heat was hell i like fixing my
electronics and like opening them up and
doing that stuff because i enjoy that
but i don't enjoy disassembling
furniture and desks i don't think anyone
does yeah i like assembling furniture i
don't like disassembling things some
people are like like so good with that
stuff and they they enjoy it they're
just like
but like disassembly furniture is like
the most depressing thing in the world
because like at least if you're
assembling furniture you have something
to look forward to yeah yeah you have
the final product what are you looking
forward to after disassembling the
furniture nothing
but that's why in the uk i used to just
put it on like websites and i'd be like
who wants it for free i'm just just
coming oh yeah yeah we we use the
service for that when we move to get rid
of our couch yeah i'm like who wants it
we're just like we just there's a
website where you can just like just put
it up for like zero yen it's like you
wanna come and get it some dude came to
get it yeah as long as you take it away
you deal with it you can have it that's
what i did in the uk with all the stuff
like i had like a
budget gaming chair
that was just broken
like oh if someone wants it you can have
it it's kind of jank it still works but
it's not great and then someone just
came yeah some russian guy came up to my
door my my son will love these chicks
and i was like all right cool
yeah i just i just don't want to do
anything in this heat like if i'm not
inside in an air-conditioned place then
i just don't want to be there like me
and sydney tried to like schedule a date
the other day where we just go out and
do something and then we realized
we always just don't want to [ __ ] do
anything outside let's just try and find
something inside because it's literally
impossible to do anything and especially
now with inside activities kind of on
lockdown it's really hard to find
anything right now yeah exactly true
true amen to that yeah you know who else
hates the summer heat our patrons
probably i don't know actually if our
patrons were here they would definitely
they would hate somebody if you're
british you i don't know if you hate
summer or not i can't stand this i
didn't until i moved outside and now i
hate the summer not as much as the
winter though yeah winter's suck doesn't
these blasting lights on us i was
swaying a lot of this episode because we
didn't turn on the air conditioning in
this [ __ ] heat so as you were talking
earlier i could literally see a giant
beat it's just because like
i've got the [ __ ] sun staring at me
and we don't even [ __ ] have the ac
the price that we you know we you can't
say that we don't care about you guys
gave me the effion facial spray which i
actually accepted and i realized that
they did nothing how the tables are
turning we suffer to make good content
for you guys so if you'd like to support
our suffering then make sure to go to
our patreon patreon.com also follow us
on twitter send us the memes on the
subreddit and if you hate our face
listen to us on spotify
yeah and i guess that's this episode
this summery themed episode of trash
taste i suppose was it summary themed
well you're dressed for the ek you know
of course you're so dressed well for the
year i'm gonna i'm gonna i'm gonna like
start a barbecue off of this right
very dad of you yes but uh anyway that's
been this episode of trash tastes hope
you enjoy your summer and we'll see you
all next time
[Music]
you